and now adjust the Box
which box because it's uh when you
adjust the actual size of the window it
adjusts on the OBS as well what's messed
up
it's a little lighter so it's going to
go off screen a little bit
it doesn't matter genre are going to
solve that box okay
let's just talk quietly over there and
I'll just wave yeah no I'm not gonna
have a fight okay I don't care if we're
live right now
we're live I mean I don't care if we're
live people need to know
all of this is really you know what John
does
what is that what is the noise going off
in your phone
koi I swear to God if we go live and
you're making noise
you're lucky you're lucky I haven't hit
the go live button yet you hear your
phone it's my fault yeah yeah thank God
we weren't alive because I don't like to
embarrass myself otherwise never you've
never been embarrassed in your life yeah
we always aspire to that all right how
long did we run this joke where we
pretend we're not live
the joke what is going on there I gotta
hit this for our podcast okay now we are
live and we are recording what is going
on there citizens of the reject Nation
we are here to talk about Spider-Man
into the spider-verse I like how across
the spider verse thank you
um jabby went live at the same time
always always copying me he knows to go
live on Sundays we have talked this
through doesn't matter if you're here
from jabby the cine Pals Channel you
make sure to come over here and you stay
here yeah I love what we have set up
here because
it looks like uh miles's chin is
protruding out he is developing some
type of unabnormal growth which is this
which is awesome
he's having a tetsuo the Iron Man sort
of transformation also you're above your
character in the thumbnail I'm above my
boys Ben and Miguel and then John and I
got it yeah Kavita over here yeah I'm so
happy not the worst I'm gonna make this
super big for us to see oh John I get
what you're getting at now thank you
guys for everyone who is yeah Super Chat
oh my God John genius John genius look
at that it's a good thing I talk nice
about you before we go live
always yeah that's that's why I have my
best energy all right guys well let's
get to it right away uh let's start to
start off with this
um spam in the chat right now spam in
the chat right now what your rating is
out of 10. let's go through uh everyone
real quick John what is your uh rating
out of 10. dude like nine and a half
maybe a ten okay that's a good rating
that's a good rating 9.9 the highest
score I've given in I think 20 years
fascinating what is the point one that
gets in the way there's a scene and this
is so so minute this is literally like I
I don't even like myself for it uh there
are two moments in the film where I
found myself on the second viewing not
the first aware that continuity was an
issue with timing for convenience and it
bothered me oh and that's literally like
the most minute but like there's a
moment where Gwen leaves and then
there's a long talk with Miguel and his
mom and then he catches up to Gwen in
like a minute and like I don't know
about that like they're both web
swinging I'm like how would you catch up
and and like this is so dumb but
nothing's perfect 9.9 yeah like that is
so close nitpick really gets in the way
and you know when Gwen leaves the portal
stays there forever
and the rest of the movie the portals
close quickly but that's it that's it
and like not it's 9.9 like that's
cartoonishly high yeah yeah we got one
three out of ten but it looks like in
the chat everything is hovering between
nine to nine out of ten here and I had
to look for a problem and therefore it's
the nitpicks these are the people that
correct everyone else um yeah I thought
this movie was probably like a 9.5 out
of I mean I don't know you guys I'm
a 10 out of 10 on this one no no that's
amazing because well the one the one
thing I I how many times have you seen
it John twice okay John has more time
than twice uh I have not seen it twice
okay I've only seen it one time uh last
week so I'm really gonna dig deep into
my memory as we talk about this because
I've seen a lot of things since then
they're all in the spider-verse though
however uh I I the only thing that
really seemed a little off to me was in
the first like
half hour or 40 minutes maybe where
sometimes it seemed like the pacing was
a tad off where it would be like really
kinetic and then it would slow down for
these really great dramatic scenes and
sometimes I'd find myself adjusting with
like oh okay I gotta slow down I gotta
slow down but I don't know if that was
just a first viewing experience I know
there were some people who expressed uh
pacing issues with this film I actually
mentioned that on my second viewing that
I like the pacing better the second time
okay because I found myself aware of how
to watch the stimuli like there's a lot
coming at you second time it actually
went up from a 9.8 to a 9.9 like I I I
literally was closer
I watch movies
[Applause]
actually off the scales no I watch
movies weird and it's even better the
second time for me alrighty well okay oh
okay I was gonna say if anyone gives a
thank you to everyone who's been super
cheap if anyone gives a 20 Super Chat I
have a thing I crew we created oh yes
moments before Oh yes that's so good oh
did you hear it already I heard it
quietly and I can't wait to hear it as
quietly I went it's a little tiny thing
but I came up with it like a minute
before John showed up and I'm like well
it's the only time it will be
appropriate for a live stream so I I
hope you guys like it but okay let's
let's play a little bit of catch up here
um Dimitri go okay hold on a second oh
yes okay John oh I know what I'm doing
John you're so money baby all right can
you read the chat I know it's really far
away sure from us boys three of us
friendly neighborhood spoiler man oh
there we go that'll make it easier so
yeah why don't you guys read I'm gonna
just refresh this really quick
[Laughter]
I am
I'm just I'm just trying to make
everything perfect hold on a second
um you're so okay you guys I agree to go
read what's going on in the chat here
that was one of my first things
acknowledge things that are going on
there while I'm fixing something well
Christopher Morris is broke and I think
we should all start a GoFundMe to get
Chris Morris back on his feet everyone's
Super Chat to get Chris Morris
and uh lots of mentions of spectacular
Spider-Man showing up yes that's what I
wanted to hear uh pocoy says exactly
like one of the first sentences out of
my mouth was across the spider versus
what we thought multiverse's Madness is
going to be uh that's one of the first
things I discussed with the group I was
with it is exactly uh what I thought it
was going to be but actually a little
bit more because of the spoiler stream
live action stuff accomplishing
something I didn't think would work I I
thought Multiverse was going to include
animation remember when we did that
trailer breakdown I was like there's
these three frames of Animation they're
gonna go into X-Men yeah and then uh
this did it but better um so this was
everything I wanted Multiverse to be in
more because the inclusion in the Canon
events actually makes our universe
included in this world which makes the
Donald Glover Cameo my favorite cameo in
the history of cameos and the way they
were able to utilize all of the elements
of the comic books like when he says the
Canon event as M90 not only is that
referencing Amazing Spider-Man 90
because that's the death of Gwen Stacy
and using those comic covers that's
actually how you log Amazing Spider-Man
to order it from the original publisher
so it makes so many things Canon because
it's a Canon event and now every time
I'm in a bad situation be like it's okay
it's just a Canon event so uh it
actually you know affected my life in a
real way did you guys know that koi is
plus one to the Spider-Man across the
spider-verse premiere his plus one
not not in Reverse this is legit he is
actual plus one if you go to social
media was Yuri who voices and does the
mocap for right he doesn't know cat form
or the Insomniac Spiderman the one from
the Spider-Man PS4 game and despite
upcoming Spider-Man 2 game as well which
design uh he does that what do you mean
the the redesigned one or the main
design one oh no the most the voice
so the face is either way yeah it's it's
him either way but he uh yeah he I
talked to him after the screening that
we saw last week and I was like dude
congratulations and I was like he was
like oh thanks man you're the first one
to confirm it like I didn't know and I
was like I'll see you Tuesday and he's
like what and I was like uh and then I
just all weekend made sure that like me
and Yuri could both go but uh Yuri is
one of my oldest friends that I and I
didn't realize the impact on I know
obviously I love the game but the spider
culture like it was so beautiful to see
so many kids and adults and and people
just enthusiastically like oh my God
you're my favorite Spider-Man so I got
to see Yuri like live the Spider-Man
life and it was so beautiful and we did
every meme on the red carpet we actually
did the entire red carpet dancing uh the
bully McGuire and uh so there's some
footage out there me and Yuri Billy
McGuire that's amazing guys okay look
I'm gonna I'm trying to balance this out
today because I know sometimes we start
talking about things and you got to
understand this feeling that happens
because we love we do appreciate
whenever someone does like contribute to
like the super chats or stream Labs but
then we're met with this guilty feeling
that if we've already talked about it
and then it's asked in there and we
don't want to be like some other live
streamers who are like already moving on
we already asked this we don't care what
you have to say so uh but there is
something that I wanted to address that
might seem a little bit off from the
actual main story uh but I saw this
going around on Twitter this morning
which was the first trailer for across
the spider verse where they it looks
like what is the name John you would
know I mean both maybe both of you know
what is the name of Spider-Man India's
world oh um
yes yes it looked like in the first
trailer my owls pierces through there
and then he starts fighting with Miguel
O'Hara there do you guys remember that
do you think that is footage from Beyond
the spiderverse oh that could be a good
call because I mean you know there would
be cause to go back there they're trying
to fix it there's been question called
in as to whether they can fix it and
pavita is part of the assembled team at
the very end so it could be that they
need to go back there for some reason
sure yeah because it seems like they
would have to do a lot of work to just
animate I mean otherwise it was just a
big mislead I mean we know marvel will
do that with like visual effects but I
don't know something that seems more
involved to do a giant animation yeah it
seems well I mean the Hulk footage is
what I always go back to of like how big
a mislead can be right but I would
imagine in the third film we're gonna
see again a lot of what we wanted on
Multiverse Madness yeah so I think
there's going to be a big sequence of
like tearing through universes which I
think might land in live action Miles
Morales but I do think that is a
sequence we're going to get what I heard
from certain screenings
um and I'm so I I'm glad that they
prepped us for it made me think of when
they did Dune and when they made sure to
put part one on there because there's a
lot of people who were not aware which
is shocking to me but I can't remove
myself from the industry I was like I've
known this for three years yeah it feels
so like a fact that it's like what do
you mean it's a cliffhanger well in the
original trailers were saying spider
were across it was called part one yeah
yeah and because of that there's there's
a lot of people who are actually upset
when it did end without uh without
having a full resolve but that's why I
love what they do specifically with Gwen
Stacy in this movie guys she gets her
movie yeah like this movie starts off
with they what I felt they decided to do
because while miles does have an arc in
this film obviously it's his plot where
the massive Cliffhanger is left at right
they made sure that they told a complete
story with Gwen Stacy at least though
yeah and starting it off with her and
then ending it off with her resolve with
her dad by the end which also you know
like because of the fact that her dad
doesn't that doesn't decide to be
captained and showing that nothing's
really going wrong in her Universe yeah
that miles is right there's a way to
show there's a way to change things
without it like causing it's not called
an incursion right not this universe
exactly what is it yeah like no but but
what if something goes wrong what do
they call that uh because I'm incursions
when something goes wrong well
incursions when the Two Worlds Collide
this isn't another world yeah this is an
implosion breaking Cannon I think is
what they called it basically okay
yeah yeah breaking Ken uh yeah I thought
that story was absolutely brilliant here
yeah I'm so glad that wasn't in the
trailers I was thinking the moment they
said the word Canon how much I would
have known about the plot like if even
if they use that word it's such a
comic-centric word it was a genius use
of hey comic fans get a little extra
juice out of this without it being
confusing I hope that the okay what's it
that's an end I'm a jog in my memory
here is it the ending of the film he's
tied up against the bag and his finger
starts to spark so I imagine that the
next scene will be picking the opening
of beyond the spider verse will be
instantly picking up from that moment
and probably getting into a fight with
Miles Prowler I could see it sounds like
you know what movies usually want to
build the suspense they might show him
there and then go back to Gwen with her
team and then go back to him I could see
that being like a cut back and forth
like crescendoing action is what I would
imagine
well I do think they did just as a
general Point like a nice job of even
though it is clearly the setup to a
second half I thought this was a
well-rounded movie and making it partly
Gwen's story sells that very nicely also
Jeff in the chat entered a headcan in
the Miguel O'Hara was the bagel and I
support that wholeheartedly
I love this I love that someone said
wasn't it called an anomaly the anomaly
is the the person The Entity that that
is the the issue like the the act of uh
so Miles himself is an anomaly but like
if you save that person they become you
know that's that's an event but the the
actual event that causes it like John
said is like oh right miles Taylor's
Prowler that's right yeah that's true
that's a good point kill okay alrighty
oh yeah and they mentioned the Sinister
Six cartel as well so yeah oh I love
that oh yeah there's a lot oh there's so
much coming in beyond the spider verse I
hope it's three hours and it's a movie
too where you sit there you watch this
one and you're like I need the DVD
because there's so many little lines of
dialogue as well that will flip by you
and you're like wait what did they say
and then you're on when it's on Blu-ray
six hour live stream frame by frame
let's do it oh uh I want you Coy you
were telling us a fun fact about this
that uh was it Phil Lord or Chris Miller
uh yeah Phil was telling me that the kid
that animated the entire Lego sequence
is not only 14 but he had to finish his
homework before they did rewrites so
whenever ever they were trying to get
any notes to this kid they had to like
talk to his parents wait for him to
finish his homework solve all the
logistical issues of being 14. yeah and
uh I got to meet the candidate an
absolute delight and it's oh you got to
beat him yeah yeah okay I also got to
meet so the Lego season he's from Canada
he's from Canada but I think I think
he's originally from Nigeria but he's
like like the family was very Canadian
uh but the um one of the most beautiful
things was Lego Spider-Man obviously a
small and the voice actor for the Lego
Spider-Man is a little person who is so
full of enthusiasm and joy and so I got
to meet him he's one of my best yeah
he's incredible so they cast a little
person to play Lego Spider-Man and also
animated by a 14 year old who had to
finish his homework for grades like that
whole sequence makes me so happy so I
got to be both Amazing Phil was
describing all the logistics of having
all the different pockets of people and
the way this whole team came together is
literally thousands of artists all over
the world and a lot of them's first or
second project yeah so it's a truly
one-on-one event in movie yeah beautiful
Luke uh the reaction we're gonna I know
we got a good amount of Super Chat just
really appreciate we will get to all
them right now there are some things
that we want to talk about
um I thought miles's reaction uh the
reaction to being into miles being in
the wrong universe
that moment I I forget when it was I
think it was when Aaron it was right
when the mom is like who's Spider-Man
yeah because what I love about the
writing of this film I feel like not
enough people talk about the actual
writing of this movie because there's
certain lines that might sound like just
a fun fact or a a part of the World
building because you know Miguel's the
one who says he's telling uh miles I
believe it's on the train you guys will
really have to help me out here well
yeah
but that's the scene when he's telling
him that it wasn't supposed to be him
that was bit uh that he took someone
else's spider right yeah and you're not
really thinking about it's more like oh
damn for Miguel and with the movie does
such a good job at doing is in that
moment when Miguel is saying that to
miles
it's to me at least as a viewer I'm
there going God that's hurtful
Michael they had an emotional first yeah
it's so painful like you just keep
telling them you're not worthy you're
not good enough all of your think I'm
not even thinking about like oh I wonder
what that universe is like with uh not
even like thinking about that but when
the mom says that I was next to Olivia
my wife and I was like oh my God this is
the wrong universe
and that and that is such a great uh
setup because I love that this movie it
does go I didn't laugh as much as the
first movie I don't think anyone does
with this film uh I didn't laugh as much
as the first movie I love how much
darker this particular one is it
progressively gets darker uh as it goes
right down to the very last moments you
know even if it's a hopeful moment two
quick things that relates to that the uh
the beautiful thing that I caught was uh
on the first viewing I noticed that in
the in his Universe the sodas are named
and in the new universe his Earth 42
that he lands in there's is a billboard
that just says soda today that was my
first uh like inkling and what I love is
that that can turn almost in your
Universe like us viewers spider sense
because my brain went and I noticed
myself looking more uh detailed and then
when I knew was right before the mom
even came in the room what happens is he
lands and he has to hide his suit so he
picks up clothes off the ground of that
universe and in all of our miles he's
wearing a black dark dark dark dark dark
dark green black jacket with a red
hoodie that's his imagery in that
Universe it's a purple hoodie and a
green jacket so he's got Prowler colors
on because he's wearing he's literally
wearing the colors of the prowler in the
prowler's universe because that's what
he would dress as so uh I noticed that
he put on the the hoodie and that it
mirrored that but also I was more
attuned to it because in the comic books
there is a Canon where Miles becomes the
prowler and that's another yet another
I'm gonna do a whole like five minute
rants on Donald Glover at some point but
that is yet another thing that ties into
that Cameo that I'll talk about later
but I think it's a really beautiful way
to subtly make you the viewer have
spiders sense like why does this feel
off what's different what's off well and
the great thing really quick about that
sequence watching it the second time is
they actually in the filmmaking like the
first time it worked so well on me I was
I had that moment of oh no and you
watch it again and you're like oh man
all the visual cues are here you see the
computer bring up Earth 42 before
Rio shows up and her eyes are green
instead of brown it's like there's so
many little tells that are terrific even
the design of Miles room is slightly
different the posters are slightly
different so like you can pick up it's
really fun to note those details on the
second time because they they trust uh
that you won't you know be if you get
them the first time then good on you you
know yeah I will say this sentiment of
this is like their Empire Strikes Back
hear that about like every goddamn part
every day
every part every part two they say that
like nowadays
this was that though this was the case
of this is like The Empire Strikes Back
of the trilogy yeah and it's rare where
I truly agree with that sentiment I
really agree with that because it is one
of those things where the story is
open-ended um by the time you get to its
closing credits and it ends off on like
a moment with like God damn I gotta
watch the next one because I need to see
the story complete yet it takes you on
such a Immaculate Journey uh throughout
yeah I I really love this movie
um it's true a lot you mentioned the
drama over the comedy before
um and and that's something I was
talking to Chris Miller about after the
first screening um that we were at was
it's basically what they did for comedy
over the last 10 years The Meta
modernism is my favorite study of art
metabolism is a sincere irony and ironic
sincerity it's this blend of
self-awareness where the audience is
part of the participation of creating so
you have to be a futurist to make a
movie in Mad monarchist sensibilities
what I hope the meta modernism of the
way Lord and Miller make their art
translates into next is is we've
accomplished the comedy being so
self-referential everything's got that
Deadpool flavor Lego Movie all those
things this is the most sincere drama
I've seen in a really long time in its
earnesty and it's wearing its itself on
its sleeve and without the honest uh
audience participation in that you don't
buy a movie with a bunch of Spider-Man
being this big of a drama you don't buy
something being this emotionally
available unless you have that
relationship with the audience and what
I hope meta modernism evolves into is a
more sincere drama so we can start being
honest with each other about like the
mental health elements the drama the
sincerity the openness and I think
that's where they're going I think
that's really beautiful maturation is
filmmakers as well as the audience
watching it and I think that's what this
movie represents and how it's like
Empire man Coy I can't wait for you to
talk about the duplicitousness and The
Duality
you better believe it yes but in the
gallery you see when they're fighting
vulture there's like a mild breakdown of
exactly their meta modern aesthetic yes
Gwen shouts out technically it's
commenting on the art but still aren't
you they're like I love that so much bag
sack thank you so much uh for telling us
about your friend man uh so the guy made
the Lego thing is Lego me online uh he
recreated the trailer as well which went
very viral deservedly so I think having
Spider-Man India's character in here was
genius because now this movie's gonna
make even way more trillions of dollars
damn it's better they really delivered
on that it also showed what happens to
Spider-Man without trauma I think
there's a delight what I love to
especially thinking about the ending was
this movie introduced a whole new set of
spiders that you mainly focus on I'm not
just talking about help me out here guys
what is it called when you where Miguel
O'Hare is running everything in the
spider Universe the community of
everyone it's better Society Society
okay uh the spiders not talking about
the star side I'm talking like spider
Punk Spider-Man India uh those guys
what I thought what I think is so cool
is like the first movie had like
Spider-Man Noir and the rest of them
right spider ham and all that yeah so
they had all those guys and then they're
not in this movie until the very end
obviously they're not in this movie and
said you get these other characters that
you other Spider-Man characters are
flesh out and then part three is gonna
be the one where you combine all the
characters
yeah yeah and you will get even more
yeah but but to watch I can't wait to
see like Spider-Man Noir interact with
some of these other guys that we gotta
meet I want him and Ben Riley to talk so
bad because Andy Samberg was doing his
best knit cage I want to see the Nick
Cage like drama off yeah oh yeah we
gotta talk about that um okay really
cool let's play a little bit of catch up
here um because I've been monitoring as
much as I can here yeah coolest courage
yeah yeah I was thinking about my past I
was very emotional right now this is a
10 out of 10 for me all right guys watch
Greg do some massive readjustments here
do it in real time same real time so
real quick other than the uh I know
we'll probably talk extensively about
this uh koi especially on your end
um John what was your personal favorite
Easter egg in the movie if you had to
nail it down I know John is really good
at narrowing things down to one thing my
face and I feel like he can do it
Easter egg yeah in this film I know you
can do it John I've never believed in
you more than I do right now um oh golly
don't worry John
be confident it's really easy to be
confident when you just tell someone be
confident yeah that's how it don't work
don't think of an elephant uh I really
really liked every Easter egg that I I
mean they were all the best Easter eggs
um
I'm trying to think of something that's
not super obvious
uh I don't know
anything spider Punk said is my favorite
so right you bought enough time for me
to get to the first super shot of today
yes
well that's the thing
that's the thing strikes in this movie
and like your brain goes on overload
just because it's like every frame is
Easter eggs on Easter eggs bag man I was
happy Bag Man was there I was happy
security guard Spider-Man showed up all
right so um for those who are not just
listening but watching uh is this visual
okay for you guys right now
um yeah do you think this looks what are
you guys
the opening frame okay yeah as long as
this looks good to everyone especially
you know these guys like they contribute
I want to make sure their names shine on
screen oh my God I messed it all up
let's see their names now now that they
have no names no they have no name no
names now they're just they're all
Robert Paulson right now all right hold
on let me just readjust this a tiny bit
bear with me ladies and gentlemen I know
what I'm doing you are the master you're
the king
I didn't catch that till the second time
Mike uh my Fjord um they have Yankee
playing Yuri Spider-Man in the dorm room
which I love very much oh is that the
game yeah he was literally playing the
Spider-Man game on ps4 I like that uh
miles also has just it's not a
Spider-Man thing it's just he has a sign
above his bed that is in the Supreme
text but it just says Sashimi yeah
I love the multiversal stuff in this one
too like the first where they had that
weird Seth Rogen poster just because
there's so many of those like details I
can't wait to frame by frame yeah
and I don't know this is just as like
there we go oh hey does this look fine
looks great we got names we got screen
we got super cute try lineup yeah the
super chat with the bottom of the chat
chat yeah so much is that our first one
John yeah yeah Johnny uh Johnny in honor
of Johnny John take it away nice
Spider-Man ranking and thank you for
your contribution today how about a
ranking from each one of y'all three on
Tarantino Nolan and Vilnius filmography
after their upcoming movies that uh I
mean I would be super thrilled to rank
all of those people's movies and to see
the ones I haven't seen from each of
them which is only a couple yeah I would
love to do that I especially would love
to do that for um I mean it might be fun
to do after Nolan's uh Oppenheimer comes
out are you are you Nolan I'm a huge
Nolan fan um but Tarantino he's working
on his last movie uh I think it's called
the movie critic right now so maybe
after Dune after uh Oppenheimer and then
after the last tarantee yeah it's true
guys the live doesn't start until koi
goes off on someone remember that yeah
someone someone uh gets some intolerance
going in the chat yeah that's your one
opportunity thank you for the Super Chat
there Johnny Bucky Barnes luck Atlanta
hey guys sorry I can't be there today
seen the movie in two hours hey oh
avoiding spoilers see you next week
appreciate you Greg John and Coy We
Appreciate You Bucky Barnes Bucky is
usually the one who is holding down uh
the fort here when it comes to you know
um making sure everything's going
smoothly in the live stream and by the
way if you're here Anarchy today please
make sure yeah like a spider Punk
Anarchy if you are here today please
make sure to leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated seriously it helps with
the playback on these things because a
lot of times we do these and people will
go I thought you guys were gonna do a
spoiler talk for spoiler review for
Spider-Man or something like that they
always say that and then I'm like we did
do it it's just sometimes the live
stream playbacks don't show up in
people's feeds a lot of the time or yeah
that'll get it up there
um Dimitri Guerrero hello there reject
Nation much love from Cali yes that's
how I imagine you sound thank you so
much fresh love too because you're
you're close thank you Dr Father Figure
uh yes okay yes this is a great one uh
Dr father figure thank you koi why don't
you read that one love you guys I think
this could Shape Up to be the best movie
trilogy ever definitely the best sequel
to the best comic book movie I actually
resoundingly agree I think there is a
lot of interesting takes on all the
Spider-Man I think all the Spider-Man
movies all 10 of them have Merit in
their own way but I pretty confidently
believe that this is the best pair of
them and if the third sticks The Landing
which I think it will I think this might
be my favorite Trilogy of all time which
is high stakes but yeah this is a
beautiful beautiful series of movies I'd
be very I've heard someone debate this
uh we'll take like let's say one minute
to do this I've heard some people say
this that there's no way this could be
the best one because it's an animated
movie it's not you know like there's
this weird thing where some people feel
like it's less than or doesn't quantify
in the same category because it's
animated I think in a lot of ways
putting an animated movie is a lot
harder to put together because you can't
just fix it in the edit you might think
that but you really gotta like map
out to a t so much so where you don't
have
you have to be a lot more meticulous and
a lot more crafty about the way you put
everything together do you know what I
mean like I think James Gunn was
actually speaking on that when he was
talking about why he was so impressed
with into the spider-verse I honestly am
probably of the three of us the one that
struggles the animation the most and
this is my favorite Spider-Man movie and
and that's just because of my connection
to character and the way I the way my
brain digests art I just prefer live
action generally but as someone who's
willing to say that that is so ignorant
to denigrate an entire medium just
because of like it being in a format so
uh yeah no that's that's like the same
people that are like we shouldn't allow
any comic book movies to be in the
Oscars uh why they're movies like the
Oscars are to celebrate Motion Pictures
these are moving pictures and everything
is a based on something like not
everything but biopics are based on a
life and lots of things are based on
books and some things are based on other
things so just to exclude an entire
medium for your own ignorance is your
own ignorance and like what Kyle's
saying in the chat too it's better
because it's animated exactly the anime
is such a big part of its character and
voice like they they really lean into it
it's not like they they cheap out with
doing and like it's part of its voice
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it has all the
heights of a big Blockbuster animated
movie but it has all the Artistry of an
indie animated movie and I feel like you
have in some ways more control over an
animated movie but also you don't have
the same kind of human nuances of
performance and so while you may be
restricted in live action to your
footage at the same time in live action
you know you have to translate so much
from scratch all right I went into three
minutes people you gotta tone it down
now at least yeah what John said is now
irrelevant Alistair McDonald John read
that in your best Scottish accent best
film I've seen this year I love that
hope views are well love from Scotland
all right
very good
this golf course I want a riotous like
whooping Scottish uh I do I can see this
going down as the best movie of the year
for myself my current favorite movies of
the year are John Wick for missing
um and I would say Guardian
I kind of prefer a couple of these other
movies over the gardening Circle mine
are uh air Blackberry Guardians haven't
seen area yet air was my number one
until Guardians and then I saw
Blackberry I was like whoa and then this
so those are my top four and those will
likely be my top ten
yeah there's something they're also
different there's something about the
movie missing that's just I love how
much you love Mrs I'm so in love with
that movie I was like this movie just
was so insane cool and I really liked
Evil Dead rise uh I love that a week
later Mystic is still like oh my God for
you she's so happy that was one of those
videos where I was like I know this is
not gonna get a lot of views that I
don't care I want whoever wants I love
it I hope they enjoy oh my God we got a
20 Super Chat get ready Tarantino get
ready guys everyone listen
[Music]
of course this is what happened
it was the quietest pause ever oh
momentous silence
[Music]
to monitor it
and it
can you guys hear anything
Super Chat look at that the media it is
playing someone can hear it can you guys
hear it
type in the chat if you can hear it here
I'll make a separate media somewhere in
the Multiverse
we need to refresh hold on a sec
oh they do hear it yeah they hear it oh
they hear it I don't know why the
monitor is okay now
obs
that's why yeah we didn't know that's
funny hold on okay hold on I need to
redo the chat here super quick
um Tech on Tech on Tech I could do it
John Style
well it's harder when you're texting me
because because it's like he's got more
like producers it's like the producers
watching and you're like oh my god
when you're out you're not aware of
something happening
um all right it's all good you're so
money baby
I'm just refreshing this
okay
that's not it
oh
John's watching him oh no
Obama Texas
what do I do I would love if somebody
had that response to my attention
Can't Screw Up in front of John
oh God
let me see this
I know I have in my head it's okay
there's so money baby so money all right
okay we just had to refresh it Chad is
fixed
wow it's so loud here's what we gotta do
we gotta run an experiment here all
right we gotta running because now we
can't hear it not only can we not hear
it but they're all they're all going
it's so loud
[Music]
I'm gonna hear them
it is so loud I just heard it's a
spectacular Spider I think a little
lower yeah lower it it's so funny to me
okay oh man all right okay so that's on
Monitor and now I'm gonna turn it down
okay because everything I don't care
what anyone says this turned out better
than I could have ever before
wrong I'm so sorry we're gonna skip my
ears
[Laughter]
this is one of those things where you
like you know you want to make your wife
happy you get her a gift and it just
totally backfires that that is what
happens with kindness there you go okay
got it oh man
uh
all right so yeah it was working it's
not working now but but they can hear it
so it's so okay so we just can't hear it
but it's at fifty percent yeah it's at
less than 50 all right everyone brace
yourselves I'm gonna play it again and
tell me if it's fine
I love that this is going to go on our
podcast but it's so loud up there it's
just using and that won't even be uh
that won't even be in here unless I find
a way to mix it oh that's fine okay I'm
gonna hit play again
this is the wooden I just hit play you
just hit no no you hit the little
eyeball this one oh you can no no don't
hit that one don't hit that hit the
spect one because that'll be the
appropriate but it says it's on is it
just going no no no because there's a
bar right here that will play when it's
playing and when it starts playing it
just put it at 50 just tell me if this
is fun
I hit it again
I love the amount of time committed all
right good or what's your actual
question we got there we got there
um
thank you guys for putting in all the
hard work that you do you're goddamn
right now
we will do what we can now they said
they can't hear it too low now all right
don't worry all right all right okay
this is not 50 you clearly said I went
to a quarter all right I'm gonna make it
a little bit loud all right
now hit the eyeball twice I appreciate
you guys no no we'll just try to the
next one thank you guys for another hard
work you guys are my favorite Channel
thank you for being patient with us how
do you think the series will end oh I
haven't even thought about that well
miles meet Tom Holland or Andrew
Garfield by the end well that raises a
great question about the live action
Miles Morales that we are going to be
having now that uh Amy Pascal has
announced it next to Kevin feige saying
it's going to be in the MCU that was a
great moment you guys get the joke yep
it made him real real happy that he was
talking about that uh but yeah the that
that I think it would prob I don't know
if it would land where he's like stuck
in the live action Universe although it
would be interesting because it'd be
kind of
do would we want to see nah you know I
would want to see personally
I would want to see this this Trilogy
conclude and it be its own thing and
then the live action Miles Morales be
something separate I personally would
prefer that
um instead of it just continuing on
because I don't feel like I feel like
you just end up comparing it to what the
animated one was the entire time you
know what I mean I think it would also
mess up the actual canonical boundaries
of things because it's established that
miles's Universe just exists in this
animated form you have live action
characters show up so I feel like if we
randomly switched him into live action
and didn't just make it so that he's
like a CG element in an otherwise live
action world I just think yeah if you're
gonna do live action miles just start
new koi you got 30 seconds girl I
honestly think that this will run
parallel to live action universe but
also allow us to be familiar with miles
so that when you introduce miles it is a
familiar character but he's gonna have
his own different take on that universe
so I do think we're gonna have Andrew
and Toby And certain live action
elements in the third film but when that
concludes it won't be the miles we've
lived with for these three movies in
live action it'll be in new miles
especially since they're not going to
use Meek more who's 28 29 as a 15 year
old kid so I think a Tom Holland s
character needs to die for a live-action
miles to exist I don't see that being
the conclusion beyond the spider verse
but I do see that running parallel to a
candid event where we might have a post
credit scene introducing that new miles
going forward
you did it koi I timed him we have a
stopwatch here in front of us now
um all right let's go up here I'll think
that ties into Madam Webb really
interestingly but that's another
question I feel like this will tie into
Madame Webb I think Sony is on a great
path of like great film okay movie great
film okay movie just put put a great
Spider-Man movie in between yours weird
Sony movies good for what this is okay
movie good for what this is okay movie
great movie good for what this is all
right guys we're gonna round two this
for the unblocked all right ready hit it
hit it tell us if it sounds okay all
right it's at 50 now yes
all right one two three
[Music]
Super Chat which is funny to me
is that better is it better comment now
one to ten when I came up with this it
was brilliant and it was funny to hear
it it was so funny but yeah maybe I
should have lowered the volume right
away yeah
we should still know you know you'll
just stick next time it's feeling
perfect much better there we go and buy
next time we can have it programmed into
this machine and and thus have even more
control nice Eon blush hey haven't seen
the movie yet going to see it tonight
but I am serious I could be and want to
be part of the crew up there when Secret
Wars comes around let's do a rewatch to
the whole MCU with new rock stars that's
just an easy assembly to do yes all I
gotta do is hit up new rock stars
got like 200 hours you can spare let's
get into it who's got editor yeah this
is gonna be a knocker it will knock this
sour no problem yeah that'd be fun no it
would be fun one of these days it's been
a while I've done that a couple of times
where I've brought people on
um who were just viewers of the channel
and I I think that's a fun thing
especially when it goes great it's
really fun when it's one of the really
socially awkward that's when it's that's
what it's really fun
um John you read this one from Jake
Colby P up in the words of Corey Coleman
from Double Toasted
10 out of 10. Better Than Sex
phenomenal movie oh this is a I do want
to talk about this
um because I actually felt this the
three times I saw into the spider-verse
and there were a couple of spider Punk
lines where I couldn't quite make it out
and I thought it was doing the thing
that happened before but then I would
ask Olivia like what did Spider Punk and
she knew exactly what he said
interesting so I couldn't tell if it was
just my ears but she knew like that
capitalism
it's a metaphor for capitalism I I
didn't hear that at all ever and people
were laughing and I was like yeah
so Davey Dan v900 thank you again for
being back here Dan v900 says did any of
you have audio issues uh I did my first
time with the opening monologue ending
monologue hobie's dialogue IGN covered
that where I had no issues at another
theater hurt the experience this is a
common sentiment that I am seeing being
expressed it's like it's like
Christopher Nolan did the sound mixing
don't care about dialogue
yeah uh I personally had no issues in
our screening ironically but then I did
have issues at the premiere so the
premiere it doesn't matter yeah that's
not the audience says
uh the opening of the premiere I
actually heard them adjust the levels
after Gwen's monologue because they were
like we were all I noticed the whole
theater going like
and there were only like 20 of us that
were at both screenings so only 20 of us
knew that she was even talking to him
that'd be wrong and then you'd hear her
a little bit but then the drums were so
loud so there were issues at the
premiere in that setting and I I want to
see it again with like you know an AMC
audience like a regular theater to see
how it's mixed but our screening I I had
a good experience I I had no issues at
all at our screening and then I had a
couple with the premiere with Hobie and
a few other things I saw it again at the
at an AMC at just one of their normal
screens and I did have that thought the
second time of like oh this is a movie
that really needs like a well-tuned one
of those like Primo Dolby sound
experiences because I was sitting there
part of the time going is the mix off or
is the mix just low right now or do they
have a different mix where the dialogue
isn't as far to the front or something
Have you seen them with the cards
they're giving out uh thanking
projectionists saying like thanks for
putting this out of seven you could updo
assemble they literally made
spider-verse like the directors and the
team behind it made cards to give the
projections when it's right it's been
much of an issue there's branded
spider-verse token wow I want one all
right John uh read it away thank him
first Diego Guevara thank you so much
for being here and for contributing to
the convo uh I rarely leave a movie
theater utterly speechless
uh and I make movie going a religious
thing Del Toro was right animation is a
medium and this is one of the best
movies I've seen in love with this film
I'm glad you agree and it is absolutely
a medium not a genre you heard here it's
kind of weird how animation still
struggles to be seen as a medium yeah we
don't specify live a live action movie
like it's just another format to tell a
story yeah it's just cultures across the
world seem to have a broader array of
like more common applications for
animation whereas here it's like adults
and adult animation is is more
entrivalent than it has been but I feel
like even adult animation has like a
kiddish skew in the states well you see
the thing is with the spider-verse film
specifically prior to this prior to
these films what we have were
live-action Spider-Man movies and then
we get this animated movie that
justifies its existence in the way of
this movie can only exist in animation
right that's the only way it can exist
when the audience has already been
prepared like the prep themselves were
live action and so I feel like there's a
much bigger argument to be made for
specifically this film the closest we'll
ever get to live action spider-verse
that I think will work as no way home
and this does another thing entirely
this has so many levels on top of no way
home I think you're right like this was
made for an animation I'm so happy for
it yeah they were like we're making
spider-verse live action I'd be like why
don't
it's Madam Webb John um that's gonna be
a good one don't because we got Madame
Webb and that's all we ever need chili
chibi koi why don't you read that buddy
chili chili uh one thing in my mind is
how the hell was Sony able to completely
replicate Lego Stop-Motion to the
original Lego movies unless they got all
the original animators they got one
animator a 14 year old boy that was
delightful and wonderful and talented
and has a big future in animation and he
had homework to do do you remember the
name of that boy I do not I mean the
channel Lego me Lego boy Lego me
something like something with me in it
he made the trailer uh so if you go on
Twitter he's got like all that stuff
pinned but if you type in like Lego
trailer Spider-Man Lego Spider-Man he'll
pop up and he's a delight how great
would it be to see it tie into The Lego
Movie
Lego Spider-Man and I think they
repurpose their best I think they
repurposed J Jonah Jameson's audio from
the first Spider-Man movie that at least
that one scene I think he's I think he's
at Nexus level being where JJ is the
same universe yeah and he should be but
also the Lego Batman Lego Spider-Man
crossover is how we get amalgam because
Lego owns the rights both just like
Funko owns the right smoke that'd be an
easier actual legal issue to get like a
dark claw in amalgam Universe alrighty
um let's go here uh Jefferson's taking
his what uh from Dan v900 again
Jefferson's taking uh his wife's last
name what's interesting notice that yeah
I did not is because I'm woke his badge
says
oh really yeah his uh that's
de-masculating I'm wondering I'm
wondering if that's gonna be he also cut
off his testicles
here you go this is why we can't have
any more children after miles yeah it
was simple I I also I'm wondering if
Jefferson Davis is going to be his name
in the new 42 in the 42 Universe right
like if the one that miles is trapped in
he finds out his dad's last name is
different that'd be an interesting
little like I must read the rest of the
Super Chat please Jesus
no Davis for him the comics explaining
why miles has his mom's last name was
convoluted when the meta reason was
Miles Davis is too famous
good point Jefferson Davis wasn't he
like a bit of a controversial figure
Federate leader leader yes I think the
writers of Spider-Man that didn't bother
to Google it was the whole Morales
family let's just call them I'm gonna
create the first Jefferson Davis yeah
I honestly uh brand knuckle Bennis is a
very very uh Progressive and worldly and
historical man I'm wondering if he was
trying to like reclaim the power of the
name and people just didn't take to it
because that's not something he would
accidentally do
um we don't know that maybe that's how
he learned Paul and I have to change the
name of our podcast uh because there's
another real spoilers out there
the cease and desist uh no we just got a
bunch of Twitter messages
which is the 2023 season assist is xylee
uh who read the last one me uh John I'm
glad thank you for being here and for
contributing to the chat uh I am glad we
got a legit Cliffhanger in this movie a
lot of Marvel movies set up for sequels
but sort of wrap up things in the movie
but this was great and I agree I feel
like this movie managed to bring it to a
point where it doesn't just feel like
the book stopped at random like it feels
like a complete
chapter but that also definitely begs
the next part of the story well that's
partly two why I think all right what
was your exact what was your bottom line
that you think Miles Morales live action
should be the same one no I don't think
so either because one thing that I was
thinking about too is that you with the
live action one they probably might want
to see him paired up with a bunch of
other Spider-Man as well because that is
our introduction with Miles Morales
Miles Morales is born of not just his
own origin but his Uncle Ben is not just
Uncle Aaron but also the Spider-Man
dying and I think killing one of our
Spiderman whether it's Toby or Andrew or
Tom would be a great introduction to
Miles well the other thing too that I
think this movie really exceeded at was
one of my main takeaways when watching
this was Miles Morales like I loved
miles and into the spider-verse I I did
but there was I was so much of the
experience was a takeaway and other
characters were a takeaway too like
while I loved him in that one when I
think about this one I'm always thinking
about miles specifically I know there's
like a lot of great Easter eggs and
cameos and spot is great I do want to
talk about spot uh we got to like find
time to really talk about spot in a
second but uh miles specifically was
phenomenal here and I really think we
should I want I want like for the live
action one for him to not feel like he
has to be in someone else's Shadow even
though usually Peter Parker does come
before one of my biggest takeaways of
why this is a five-star film for me and
I looked at all my five star films and a
big through line for me of what makes a
movie perfect is when it transcends
either the original or the medium and
this does both yeah I personally enjoy
Miles Morales more in the movies than in
the comic books like I find miles more
captivating in this translation and I
usually enjoy a comic book better as a
comic book like no way home I enjoy more
than the spider-verse Saga because I
think they accomplish something unique
to the medium this I enjoy More Than
Miles Morales or The spider-verse Saga
so this is a clean five for me because
this miles is more interesting so I
totally agree and the twist at the end I
think serves this medium better the idea
of Miles V miles is much more
interesting in the medium of animation
for me true true that oh my gosh John oh
really I don't know I don't know if this
converts to 20 because I don't know at
our INR Indian conversion money oh sure
so we're doing it we're doing it we're
doing it everybody listen
[Music]
let's see the thingy hit the eyeball
again we're gonna hit it again
where's the thing this will not stop
causing me just three hours of problems
[Music]
Super Chat yeah sound waves are great
yeah
who reads this one Spider-Man movie The
Story everything is great I do feel uh
getting kind of bored in the first 40
minutes overall it's a 10 and a special
mention to Spider-Man India as an Indian
it was so great to see him and the world
of mumbatan
everything was culturally perfect I
loved absolutely loved him in this movie
because he his when he comes onto the
screen so much tragedy is associated
with Spider-Man and he is the complete
antithesis to it I just love his whole
approach of how how uh like being
Spider-Man's easier yeah
uh very relatable and and I love the the
whole thing about actually let me try to
find this comment while we're on it I
think I saw someone mention it about the
dad while you look at it I also really
enjoyed that I found it already you
better hurry up I'm fine you go ahead
and talk I won't even say the thing it's
not that I want to talk I just want to
like tie it into this yeah go ahead and
have that it says wait how is inspector
sings death Cannon when the spot and
miles are both anomalies so the spot
shouldn't have been in that world to
begin so we'd have never destroyed the
alchemix building well that's what
literally Miguel's trying to stop is the
anomalies caused things that should have
happened so it is Canon that it happened
because it shouldn't have been able to
be Canon like the it made a new Canon
the problem is Canon was him not being
there him being there is why Miguel has
to change things but he was Miguel was
upset that he saved inspector Singh
right and
um so that's that's what his question is
coming at so I guess like spots still
shouldn't have been there I think he
would have died he should have died
right I'm saying like he would have died
in another way which would have been he
would have died in whatever he had
natural way he was supposed to whereas
this is just muddying that whole process
I get I get where your confusion is
coming from but I think it tracks uh and
the thing I was gonna say was I love
that the Spider-Man humor translates
between my I thought it was really
clever to have miles open with ATM
machine M is for machine which drives me
crazy to just like pin number the end
and pin number is number and then the
chai tea are redundancy I love that
there was a parallel of humor in the
Spiderman one that even Miguel has a
certain humor even without becoming
jokey but that's what I mean that they
have the same problem like chai tea and
ATM machine are the same issue and I
thought that was a clever way to have
the humor parallel sure well I love how
do you pronounce his name who Spiderman
India uh paviter I'd have to look
I I always get the last name I want to
say pavarker but I don't think that's
exactly right uh rocker 327 thank you so
much he is asking how do you think the
score and soundtrack impacted the movie
huge uh I think it hugely impacted the
movie
uh yeah I thought it provided a great
sense of um
impulsive as John would like to say but
it also had some great foreboding
elements in it as well was there Duality
there was a duality and duplicitousness
to a lot of these shows
trapping the base The Duality no I
thought puppeteers
uh yeah it's uh
say confidently pavita prabhakar I think
it's supposed like a man I think it's
supposed to obviously kind of evoke
Peter Parker but yeah yeah
um uh yeah what were we just saying
before that though
like there's so many great VI like I
thought this movie wove really nicely
between these soundtrack elements and
the score elements and I thought what
Metro Boomin did with the vibe of the
overall movie shifting from Vibes to
these really eerie uh unsettling like
distorted sounds really just evokes like
worlds coming apart and I thought it was
beautiful I also thought they did a
really good job of the score making it
feel like it's different universes I
thought that Spider-Man 299 score being
a different flavor but still some like
parallels two miles of score and also
the use of uh aggressive horns that they
did so well in prowler's world really
tie into the universe of miles and I
like that that like almost elephant
sound is the sound of Miles universe but
they're able to incorporate that in
other worlds and um I've been listening
to the score pretty much non-stop
actually went for a run to it and it's
really interesting how motivating
certain elements are and how like uh
emotional other elements are so when
you're not doing a task that is uh mood
dependent it's interesting like just
running I was like I'm slowing down and
I didn't catch myself like
subconsciously it's that strong of a
score
and yeah as shouted out by ricotron 7. I
was talking about the spot vision
soundtrack that was I think they used it
they because with spot especially that
we really got to move on the spot
especially he starts off so funny but
then we give these teases via his music
of no there's something truly menacing
about to come with this guy before we
see him like really start to have the
Dark Matter transformation yeah
um let's see here let's see here
uh who read the last one
is what my abuela would say in place of
goodbye hearing miles mom say a tune
with such love absolutely broke me I
loved all the elements of other
languages not being subtitled because
life doesn't have subtitles uh whereas
like I really like the to be continued
at the end being the comics I loved I
adored that they put in the old thought
bubbles not as speech bubbles but as the
squares that comic books have but they
didn't do that with language because in
life you don't have those so I really
enjoyed all the language because New
York is not a place that is just English
and I really like that it felt like New
York because of that I like that it
represented different cultures so
beautifully I loved the entire scene on
top of the rooftop because I've been to
those parties I've been to that
Gathering it felt so authentic to have
so many different languages bounce
around and that is a huge part of what
makes Miles Morales so unique is those
two cultures and I love the scene in the
opening with the guidance counselor
reflecting that them talking about those
cultures and not making it like
heavy-handed so yes agreed loved it uh
yeah what are we talking about language
yeah I think the next time I show you a
foreign film I'm going to be like life
doesn't have subtitles koi deal with it
so learn to pick up on this man
that's the trick you don't watch other
movies I I thought the mom would in a
lot of ways was like the big heart of
this movie you know what I mean I
thought that she was like it's cool that
the first movie had so much more amp
even though the Dad's life is what's at
stake in this movie I felt the mom was
more the heart of this film uh between
the relationship between her and miles
it was because I didn't I don't really
think about with her you know uh
when I think about into the spider-verse
yeah I really don't actually I can't
really think of anything
but yeah a lot of those scene you really
see the difference in Dynamics and
relate like the specifics of the
relationships of what miles has with his
mom and and how tender that is I thought
that was beautiful what's going on Mohit
money are in the chat is setting us
straight pavitra prabhakar is the Indian
pronunciation shut up John
shut up Mega
um oh yeah and Yankees playing
Spider-Man two not Spider-Man one
apology Spider-Man two and he's not your
guy in the chair I like that they
acknowledged how they just made Ned
Genki and like sassily were like no
that's not who I am and also guys
beating him up at school yeah we gotta
we got a really big super chat I got it
I gotta make sure yes I gotta make sure
we say oh my God
I'm just gonna oh
you too long it's okay don't worry about
too long don't worry about it oh no
we're back we got this we're Looney
Tunes let me find it everyone everyone
be quiet
yes yes Tom Holland should play live
action Miles Morales I think people will
be very if people don't get out there if
that were to happen and be like you know
I just don't see how you should change
the race of a character from what he
originally was you know if we could have
black people play white people why can't
white people play Black people yeah Tom
Owen looks like I'm not gonna think
about this at all and understand what
the difference is nah dude one to one
it's all the same we live in an equal
meritocracy what are you talking about
Gabe de cosca decasso always giving so
much thank you so much you have earned
it do it you have earned it this truly
is a
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah it's funny because out here it's
just silence for five seconds
he says
this movie was something I wasn't
expecting and I loved that there's a lot
of ways this Trilogy can end and that
possibility makes me even more excited
if the third movie lands which I'm sure
it will hands down can be one of the
goat trilogies in cinema you know what I
really love about it too
that one of the first pieces of
apprehension that Greg had conjured up
in his soul the duplicitousness of being
excited but worried of little Duality
experience
the nervousness that came up was when
they changed the directors you
know yeah and and I'm like why would you
do that this movie the first one was
like a phenomenon don't do that that's
crazy talk and then they managed to
deliver something even better yeah I
don't know if I've ever seen a Trilogy
uh be a five and then have another five
ever uh and what I I've trained what I
found out too I I believe if my
information is correct is that these
directors are the same ones that did
Avatar and Legend of Korra uh both shows
which I have completed uh watch them on
our patreon uh original host watch along
some food oh yeah I think I think that
was and I love the animation especially
the fight sequences and once I was told
that after watching it that I was
reflecting on certain sequences like oh
yeah I can see that now
um that's crazy I mean what what a step
up I love that I don't even remember the
names of any of the directors of any of
these films because there's like 14 of
them yeah I don't I'm a monster and I
don't either I just I I know that the
spearheaded by Lord
it does suffer from that one thing
unfortunately is that like it's like
like Nightmare Before Christmas that a
lot of people don't remember uh did
Seoul as well no way I love Seoul um
yeah and Chris Pratt should play when I
was dead in live action I thought Miguel
O'Hara was more terrifying God I love I
love the chase sequence incredible also
I thought the one of the things I
thought was so in my love of meta is
that they made spot a villain that we
became miles over the whole ride to the
movie we were like spot's gonna be like
a throwaway villain of the week and then
they referenced that in the movie and
then the the reason he becomes a bigger
villain is out of pure need we'll talk
about spot more but I love that we
judged him just as the movie judged him
and I think that's what makes this
Trilogy so interesting is the first
movie the villains are big movies and
big villains you expect the second movie
he's unique to miles in Universe they
picked a villain that is in our universe
not that terrifying and they made him
specific to miles's Universe unique so
there's so many levels of meta diving
into the conversation around those
elements within his universe that is
brand new and unique to us well it seems
like what will probably happen in part
three
me might sound a little predictable but
it's all about the journey on how you
get there is that eventually you know
Miguel O'Hara and the and miles will
have to put aside their differences
because they got a lot of different
plots set up you got miles Prowler Tales
Prowler uh he got you you got Miguel
O'Hara you got Gwen stepping in to help
uh the debate about what if he does save
Jefferson and then you got spot and spot
like this movie like centers it would
spot being the antagonist but he's kind
of I feel like the third movie that
they'll have to eventually put us other
differences and all the Spider-Man will
have to work together to stop spot
because even after watching I'm like I
have no idea how you'd stop this guy I
just have no clue well yeah they don't
have to science their way through it
yeah that's what the finale is I'm doing
science I love the growth and I mean
that would be so fun I like I love the
growth and the Arc of that and the way
that yeah spot goes from being this
innocuous thing to being more of a
threat and then to just giving way to a
situation that is really bad and we
don't even yes yeah like saving the
actual like let's go get and fight him
for later yeah he went from like villain
to Roland emmerich film like it's it's a
an actual Zeitgeist shift villain I love
that so much and I and I do think you
know even though we know that is an
element there's so many other elements
it isn't predictable because that's just
one piece of a puzzle yeah there's a bit
of like a
xenophobic quality that Miguel has
towards miles I like there there's
something about like you were not
supposed to be I'm not xenophobia that's
not the right word for it
um
I think there's a general other ring
he's he's a racist yeah there's a
there's something about like baptism
he really has this disdain for what he
is well I think that's you know a
beautiful way to have an anti-hero
actually be an anti-hero I think we
always have anti-heroes be like just
light villains whereas I love that
Spider-Man 2099 was someone doing the
right thing the wrong way he's trying to
solve hits the trolley problem do you
hit the one person or do you hit these
hundred people and that's that's the
beauty of what Spider-Man 299 faces is
Miguel O'Hara is a good guy in the comic
books and he's a good guy here he's just
in the comics and here handling it wrong
I've always loved that Miguel O'Hara is
the only Spider-Man or the first
Spider-Man to have uh offensive
abilities with his wall crawling because
um he he has Talons that make him crawl
so he's literally like puncturing the
walls as he's climbing and he uses those
Talons offensively like he'll rip you to
shreds but he's a good guy and that ties
beautifully in how he handles the mile
situation he's he's got these elements
of anti-hero and in the comics it's
because you grows up in a world where
Nuevo York is dangerous and it's gone
wrong it's like Batman things have like
tipped the scales to the point where he
has to be this aggression so I love that
they were able to tell all of that in a
way that ties to Miles and make it that
kind of aversion to okay the greater
good greater good and then the movie
ending on like we're supposed to be the
good guys it's a beautiful and nuanced
conversation yeah absolutely you did
good koi
um and hey Roman Yoder thanks for
keeping a look out here
um Dan v900
uh John take it away absolutely my head
Cannon is that may day has to be an
anomaly Peter chose to have kids due to
miles miles as an anomaly didn't break
the world with that Peter dying Miguel
was wrong the Canon events were awesome
yeah yes
[Laughter]
my head count is that Mayday has to be
an anomaly because him meeting miles
causes that baby and they mentioned that
specifically Peter chose to have kids
due to miles
miles as an anomaly didn't break the
world without Peter die but Miguel was
wrong the Canada events were awesome
[Laughter]
yeah but I think I I I'm curious to know
what you guys did because I think it
checks only in that it's not disrupting
a major staple of the Spider-Man
character really like I feel like there
are iterations where Spider-Man and or
Peter and Mary Jane have a kid right
really quick I I don't feel like it's I
think there are certain events that are
like it's sacrilege to break it
basically you know like ASM 90. the
captain has to Die the captain has to
die right the uncle has to die or some
like that Crime Alley has to have
there's some things that that can just
happen you know yeah but there's certain
things that they they are a must they're
scripture they have to go by you know
they're Canon I was gonna say this is a
lot like the inverse of the captain in
mumbatendying is that it was gonna
happen anyway so I think Peter and Mary
were going to have a baby anyway so it's
not causing a candid event because yes
him wanting a kid sooner because of
Miles might be a thing but it's not like
they weren't gonna have a kid anyway
just don't tell certain comic writers
writing horribly
all righty Jack McHugh thank you so much
Jack let me just uh make sure we're good
do you think we will get a tease John if
you waste my G fuel I swear to Christ
what are you talking about I've drank so
much of that let me hold the can yeah
yeah I'm gonna finish this that's about
a two-thirds about a two-thirds full
it's about a two-thirds I'm pacing
myself I don't want to have to jump up
and pee that is a man who is drinking
his dad is a man who stops videos to go
pee though he's not wrong he's not wrong
you should see this I love you dearly a
lot of people and it's fine it's easy to
cut it out but also I'm trying to Pace
but that's smart this man peace
the streamlab link isn't working John
what'd you do I did no such thing I did
nothing at all fix it I will is it
because of this ad who is she it
shouldn't be why is she ever she's got
exclusive gear we should follow it away
we should follow the link and see what
she has to say
um check the pin comment no okay all
right
where is it
unpinned message just add the other one
from the document there what document
here
I hit pages and it'll open up it should
open up John please uh give me the mouse
I know where it is just tell me go into
downloads
jeez first you don't drink your G fuel
you gotta go up to MCU DCU news
or just this one someone in the P God's
Gonna Be peeing so much coming
God John
everyone be quiet
we're doing right now there you go now
we're in a third can you just shoved
fuel it's about to be all the way up
like I Am weigh it mother go to the
bathroom go to the bathroom
leave a like on this video so John goes
to the bathroom Troy Jack McHugh for
crying out loud do you think we'll get a
tease to a live action miles and Beyond
the spider verse I hope not I hope not I
think that would be distracting it would
be take away the whole talk of whatever
this epic conclusion ought to be focus
on this movie I don't want it I don't
want it there's also and a lot of people
aren't talking about this which is very
interesting to me when Lord and Miller
signed a multi deal with the devil which
is why the movies are so good no when
they signed uh like that multi uh uh
picture deal with uh Amazon and
Sony to do a show there's spider-verse
TV coming so I I think there's gonna be
a lot of stuff and I think that there
might be a post credit scene with live
action miles but I wouldn't expect it to
be too much uh Incorporated in the
actual film who cares about this TV
shows am I right guys always they're
less than what's TV anymore just ask
Loki in one division
alrighty yeah the worst the worst
guys Bronson right wolf is saying let's
talk about the bad audio during the
narration parts we just talked about
that we did touch on that about 40
minutes ago we did touch on that we
can't create chapters in real time find
yourself a premium screen creates a
problem here yeah good throw down for
the good sound brodinson right and well
hold on I gotta keep us on track here
um okay I got this uh Bronson right wolf
Thank You Toby Maguire is and always
will be the best Spider-Man game
he brought the right amount it's okay
yeah it's okay you're wrong uh he
brought the right amount of anger
charm and nerdiness to the character I'm
gonna use this moment to talk about the
Donald Glover Cameo because for some
reason we haven't talked about anything
like in depth yet it'll come but uh yeah
I'd like well actually you know what
really quick
um I was a bit distressed I thought it
was like kind of cool and crazy but also
a bit distracting seeing the footage
from like Spider-Man uh I thought it was
perfect because they're Canon events I
thought it was a great way to bring it
in bit distracted interesting it
actually is the Andrew Garfield moment
where I was like it's gonna be so hands
a little weird just seeing it I was just
so aware of what they're doing in that
moment I guess yeah it's just very
apparent that you took a piece of
uh like I I almost feel like if they had
had an alternate take on hand which is
like asking a lot but like you know yeah
it's like oh it's just a scene from the
movie that you threw a film yeah a lot
of people are talking about like this
like the cool cameos from Toby and
Andrew I'm like let's just footage from
the movie they have the right yeah
arguably wouldn't like a frame of a
comic book cover be the exact thing is
how we perceived that angle from the
comic from the movie like that's the
view of the viewer of that moment so
they need to use the angle from the film
because that is how we perceive it so
just as you have an artist choosing the
cover that's what makes it Canon so
those are the Canon images of that event
occurring in that universe so it's
necessary
in my opinion yeah I'm nitpicking that's
fine
uh I think Toby McGuire firstly to
answer your question authentically I
love that people love Toby and anyone
can wear the mask and anyone is going to
have their favorite Spider-Man that's
what's beautiful about this character
he's my least favorite Spider-Man in the
history of Spider-Man but it's your
experience in life
we've lived different lives you've fixed
it you have a you have a different life
therefore you have a different
Spider-Man yeah yeah whatever just say
for sure this is how you're silence so
so we all
everyone present here on the stream on
video agrees that Toby is the best I
mean some of us read more comics than
others so I'm not saying that makes us
more accurate but it's going to need
a bit more of an edge it's over here
it's different koi it's a different
medium it's not very spider Punk of
yukoi I mean yeah the establishment
likes Toby I'm gonna on it fun me
Productions a great to see you again
funny filmmaker over here Never Say
Never uh Josh Keenan Cameo oh this is
Greg's Moment of Truth Greg's moment of
truth even though it's not a 20. it's
one about Josh Keaton's my God what is
wrong with this mouse because you're
still over on the other screen
ah it's an illusion
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay so the Josh Keating Cameo uh what's
why I love that okay a lot of you guys
might not be aware of this
um is that there's The Spectacular
Spider-Man series which in my opinion is
an amazing show and I kind of like I
think I prefer no I don't think I know I
prefer it over the 90s animated series
uh and even though it does not finish
because there was this whole thing with
like Disney buying in this if I
ever finished it right like they just
never they never actually finished the
show and it sucks because it ended on
such a brilliant Cliffhanger uh I was
gripped into it I thought it was going
to be one of those shows where I was
gonna watch like homework assignment
because sometimes I have to do that here
you know I think all of us have that at
some point with what we're doing for
like our living is that we have
sometimes we have to watch that is
like I don't really want to watch this
but I kind of have to because I got to
get the information and that was one
where I just was like itching to keep
watching and then it just just
stopped and I wasn't even and the thing
is no one actually prepared me for that
so I even though I didn't watch it in
real time of it airing by the time I
finished the DVDs before they hit
streaming because it was my friend Aaron
Alexander he got it for me but I
finished the DVDs of it I was like oh
damn I gotta buy the next ones I was
like what do you mean there's no more
like that I still got the feeling that
everyone else got which is oh you gotta
be kidding me like this ended
like this it did not get a conclusion
um and Josh is the best so I would love
to see and you said you got you gotta
hang out with him yeah yeah so Josh
plays elektro in the uh the video games
and uh so I I didn't know that yeah I
know Josh through Yuri and uh it was
really funny to be in I hate you
Spider-Man he goes from both times but
it was really funny to be at the
premiere With Yuri and then like talking
to Josh because I went across the
spider-verse like in my brain I was like
these are the two voices of Spider-Man
and they're both like those guys to to
so many millions of people so uh the
fact that he crossed over like Donald
does into Elektra was really funny to me
and Josh is his passion for the
character is like insane so there was a
moment where it was me Josh Yuri dance
slot Bendis Lord Miller Aldous Hodge and
uh Sam Richardson all talking about how
we perceive Spider-Man and none of it's
relevant the names are relevant for the
story but like it was I got you you're
good you're good I love you buddy it was
interesting
no Corey please no don't be like Joe it
was really cool to hear how perspective
it was really cool to hear our
perspectives of Spider-Man vary by your
life experience even when you've played
him the way you perceive the character
is so unique so to have Yuri describing
Spider-Man authentically and to have
Josh describing authentically his
version that was the the culmination of
his entire universe and they both like
had time to really uh gesticulate how
they're perceived and then to have
people that love them like
Sam and eldest and all these people that
have viewed them and then to have people
that have written him like Venice and
Dan who never played him all of the
perspectives on Spider-Man were
different but they all had these
beautiful through lines it was one of
the most amazing conversations I've ever
had with spy brought it up that was no I
was I honestly would have loved to have
been a fly on that wall I just I don't I
know it's name dropping it's just
no more stories no I like it Koi Koi
your monocle is joke no drop the names
as necessary koi I am here for you I I
will pay for names John please take it
away G Kobe P thank you for being a
lovely lovely person and joining us
today loved Gwen's Ark hot take I love
Emma Stone but I found it I love how I
said we were going to talk about the
Donald Glover again
don't talk about it because we know
people are going to bring it up and no
it's probably we literally opened up the
thing with like I see it in the live
chat right now so I'm like we just gotta
talk about it all right but don't please
continue it I love okay so hot take here
uh from G Colby P I love Emma Stone but
I found her to be nothing more than just
a bland love interest and a convenient
plot device in the chasm films Haley
steinfeld's Voice work is amazing here
very true I would definitely compare
this Gwen to that Gwen you know I think
it's an even comparison that's as hot as
my token requires the worst Spiderman
tape that is a hot tape I think Gwen is
one of the best parts of The Amazing
Spider-Man her and Andrew kind of save
that because their chemistry is
wonderful yeah I feel like she brings so
much more like I I think the thing you
cannot argue is even if you prefer the
Remy ones even if you like Spider-Man 2
I sorry to tell you this question it's
okay myself and probably a vast majority
of the world prefer Spider-Man 2 over
The Amazing Spider-Man see my ranking
noise comic quarter
um I do prefer The Amazing Spider-Man
over Spider-Man 2002
um I do prefer that uh but the amazing
but Spider-Man 2 is my favorite of them
all I don't care what anyone says though
you cannot
like Emma Stone and Garfield is way
better than Toby Maguire and Kirsten
Dunst like Annie Davis
Toby McGuire should definitely break up
a very happy marriage for no reason and
he should definitely make out with Gwen
Stacy in front of Mary Jane before he
even has the Symbiote because that's
what Spider-Man would do
what is your deal with going after Toby
did you lose him in a poker match or
something I'm not saying there's a movie
based on his addiction to Poker and rage
but I am saying that Laura guevira Saya
in the chats as you deserve to flex and
I agree you should Flex those names but
you should also Flex those guns really
quick just I mean I've been training
like uh Spider muscles look if they're
too big for yourself working on the
triceps up the thing is really hard you
have to get a certain amount of body fat
to get there and it's not been easy that
said uh I think Emma Stone added an
intelligence to win that she was missing
and a lot of adaptations because what I
consider Gwen Stacy is one of the
ultimate versions of Peter's loss right
the character is all about loss and how
you handle loss power and responsibility
is is usually misquoted is it's not just
with great power comes responsibility
it's great power must also come
responsibility it's the idea that
there's an action required so for me one
of the issues is in Spider-Man series
it's got to be a it's got to be a choice
right so Spider-Man can be angry it
makes sense we're all full fleshed out
human beings anger is a natural reaction
but it's the choice to not live angry
that I struggled with with Toby there's
a lot of characters that make decisions
and then like it leads them on a path or
another with great power there must also
come great responsibility is the
actionable task of being responsible
even when it doesn't serve you even when
it's at a loss to you Gwen Stacy
represents that to so much to me because
to me Mary Jane had to change as a
character and evolves a character when
you lost Gwen Gwen was who Spider-Man
was meant to be with Gwen is his
intelligent equal Gwen was his his
compatriot went in school he got made
fun of Mary Jane at the time is a party
girl she was dating Harry Osborne she
was going out clubbing but when
Spider-Man lost Gwen Mary Jane saw what
that meant to the entire community and
how she had to find a way to Rally she
had to find a way to summon the strength
even though at home things were a mess
even though at home things weren't
working out for which is why her defense
mechanism was partying the loss of Gwen
impacted every single person in the
entire Spider-Man universe and without
her being being as intelligent as the
Emma Stone take without her being as
important you don't have the impact of
Mary Jane so I honestly think what Gwen
Stacy represents is the catalyzation of
not just Peter Parker but also Mary Jane
and I think Emma Stone was one of the
first people to ever find that in an
authentic way that endeared us to her
not just romantically but as her own
individual character making the entire
universe better
my tick
it's perseverance I I appreciate it but
where admire your resilience always but
the thing is
you look like Spider-Man from the Magnum
PI Universe it's a little extra thick
and a little no I don't apologize sure
no no
I told you baby you know what spider cop
was in this movie and frankly he didn't
pick a screen time he deserves it he was
chilling there's so that's the thing is
there are so many Spider-Man I noticed
that I like tried to make mental note of
and then yeah Christian
unpronounceable what the oh now
you've done it what's happening we're
going to Christian unpronounceable
checking it out he doesn't have any
content here what is going on delightful
guys
cool we're back we're back we're back
hold on let me fix this yes
I don't know don't you guys just stop
listening to koi after a while I mean
some do I think koi does every single
spider person who appears in the movie
have a corresponding comic book aside
from the specific video game only ones
uh I can't get off topic guys we must
keep the stream moving we have a hard
out at 250. Pin that
I'm ready like the stream you filthy I
like this stream you filthy animals says
Christian unpronounceable we love you
bud alrighty
koi
I thought the Donald Glover Cameo was
amazing
the Donald Glover Cameo there's a whole
history with the Donald Glover Cameo I
mean Miles Morales was inspired by
Donald Glover wasn't is that the story
of how it goes that he was inspired by
Donald Glover dressing up as Spider-Man
and even making a joke about wanting to
play Spider-Man and then they created
miles via that may I
yeah sure in 2010 there's a very very
successful internet campaign one of the
earliest internet campaigns to go to
scale this is a very big cultural event
called Donald for Spider-Man in the
Donald for Spider-Man campaign there was
basically a moment at the opening of
Community season two episode one where
Donald puts on a Spider-Man shirt wakes
up in bed and basically announces man
I'm gonna be Spider-Man this is this is
the moment or he starts like
incentivizing people to get him as
Spider-Man this is around the time
they're about to cast Andrew Garfield so
there was a high likelihood a High Hope
of Spider-Man being Donald Glover
because he would have been perfect
basically when that didn't happen Brian
Michael Bendis the inventor of
Spider-Man acknowledges that part of the
creation of the look and the vibe and
the feel of Miles Morales was based off
Donald Glover So In This Moment Donald
Glover became a Canon part of Spider-Man
in real life years go by and Donald puts
it in a lot of his raps there's
literally a lyric was uh you didn't want
to see me as Spider-Man's now I'm
spitting Venom like he's literally
acknowledging that this was a thing that
almost occurred now Donald Glover is one
of the artists that is also known for
multiverses in his work the album
Because the Internet is one of the most
uh accurate and futuristic and prophetic
pieces of metamodernist art because it
is not only an album that represents
Donald Glover but it also represents
Charles Gambino which is one of the
elements of Donald Glover that he has
invented to use his art form and the
child which is a script Donald Glover
wrote about the experience of going
through because the internet much like
Pink Floyd's Dark Side of the Moon so
Donald Glover being a meta modernist in
himself and basically being someone that
blends these worlds is inherently meta
to the universe of him being cast in
this movie years later making it one of
my favorite cameos now top of that
Donald Glover in Spider-Man homecoming
is a character who is playing Aaron
Davis so Aaron Davis is inherently based
on Donald Glover because without the
character of miles you don't get to
Aaron Davis so when they cast him as
Spider-Man homecomings Aaron Davis he in
fact mentions his nephew lives in that
town he wants to keep him safe he talks
about climbers but we never had the
opportunity to have him evolve into the
prowler so Donald is now playing his own
uncle but a Year's a couple years
earlier he voiced Miles Morales so he
got to actually self-actualize the
version of himself that got to play
Miles Morales in the first ultimate in
Spider-Man game so now we have Donald
Glover basically playing his own Uncle a
version of Miles Morales in the
Multiverse a version of him that is
referenced in into the spider-verse
because the scene of Donald for
Spider-Man is actually what Aaron Davis
is watching and into the spider-verse so
Aaron Davis in the candidate into the
spider-verse acknowledges the Aaron
Davis of our universe being Miles
Morales while also having all those
things go forward and then at the end of
all this in this movie we have him
finally evolve into being fully the
prowler in the prowler get up that he
was supposed to land in in the first
Spider-Man homecoming acknowledging the
metamodernism of this entire universe in
one beautiful Cameo Donald for
Spider-Man 12 years in the making
perfect Cinema
nicely done
there was a few other elements but I
left some out I'm gonna make a tick tock
about it but that is the short version
12 years in the making 12 years in the
making
it deserves a standing oh my boy if I
wasn't so much right in the camera so
much for you and there's more but that
that's the that's the Highlight that was
magic I didn't know half that stuff
that's all for Spider-Man means so much
to me and I'm so happy for Donald Glover
it makes me so happy there's also little
details like John Francis Daly uh who
wrote Spider-Man homecoming is also
someone that works with Lord and Miller
on uh the the spaghetti cloudy this
chance of meatballs and they're the two
meta modernists that work most closely
with Donald Glover so even the inherent
in-joke that we get there's more inside
jokes that they get it's beautiful dude
he should release a follow-up album
called because the spider verse next
Super Chat yeah Chloe I thought that was
uh that was brilliant guys it was good
that was good that was a bit that was
all of us working together that was a
solid gold that was good info good
physical comedy zooming good editing
comedy yeah
that's not wrong dude Chloe on estrogen
thank you for being here hope your
hormones are doing well I I love the
trans flag above Gwen's door and you
know what Gwen's universe and a lot of
her just whole room has the the pink and
blue color palettes you know that that
you know Peppers the whole thing that's
what cracks me up when people are like
this is my face you know I love
on people who like get mad at what
culture all the time because half the
time it's not the real thing right
this movie is so woke like spider
spider bucks
that's just great use of those vibes
yeah
and people like are seeing the same
people being like this is what happens
when you don't make a book I'm like
[Music]
I think it's funny and then even like
the like I saw the trans flag I did see
the trans uh flag and the protection
protect kids yeah on the first viewing I
caught it was like a split second I was
like I wonder how many people are gonna
yell at the screen over that
um even though he's like it's a blink
and you'll miss it moment but you know
there are some people who will not miss
it and be like I was looking for it but
yeah I'm like there's so many like even
Gwen's world I think it was it the dad
wear like a uh something about trans
lives too uh Captain Stacy I believe he
does have something like that as well
you got the BLM sign too yeah yeah and
the bisexual lighting of her Universe
yes that's what I was thinking yeah yeah
yeah that whole scene is like so guys
it's it's like
like while spider Punk is very much used
like Jake Santa chapter comedic effect
it just it just makes me personally
laugh when these people who constantly
scream are like it's not I'm like the
fact this is one of the focused comic
book movies I've seen in a while it also
shows like 90 96 Rotten Tomatoes score
on the people's side shows that all of
these people that complain about
don't realize what that word
means yeah like it makes me so happy to
be like yeah those those same people
that get mad at stuff are like that
movie's great though it's doing progress
in real time that you just missed this
is so it's so funny I used to love the
word woke and now it's so agonizing to
deal with because it just calls like the
thing is yeah it's the movie is pretty
woke I would say just in that it's
pretty tolerant and representative you
know like well yeah I think uh which is
what Progressive used to be for black
people now it's taking on this hole
originally it would hijacked like a
bunch of black cultures yeah like woke
was about being aware of things in
certain areas and being aware of certain
people and now it's literally a Mad Lib
for anything you want if you're on the
other side it's just like this movie has
like every regard every everything that
people have yelled about I'm like it's
it's so in this room yeah and it just
cracks me up that I'm like oh they can't
see it
why can't they see it
I fully expected it to be I give it a
week it'll turn what was the is it funny
yeah Pedro Sanchez
um uh thank you Pedro it was nice seeing
all the little nods to Rio and Miles
being Puerto Rican in this movie from
the snap to the dialogue makes one happy
to be from Puerto Rico
and what's what's that line he says
about like oh no he sounds like he's
Dominican to me like I got a big laugh
uh in the theater uh with with the
people's Bean woke is not the entire
movie it's not uh well it's either it is
99 of the things that they yell about
that's what I'm getting at is it an
acceptance equality and taking care of
it is pretty well downstairs like yeah
the Boomers they yell at it's not
Valenti I am with you like I I actually
I love the word and what its intent is
and I yeah I just hate the way you know
the people who are anti have hijacked it
and taken all the joy out of it yeah I
agree that's exactly the issue and
you're goddamn right you should protect
trans kids absolutely
um yeah and if you don't believe that
then
leave a Super Chat and then unsubscribe
yes
it's on your way out yeah
how much you hate you hey
yeah
the longer time will dedicate it's a
win-win I'm sure we'll be having the
gamer MJ I don't think donkey was
playing Spider-Man PS4 yeah you idiot I
wasn't aware he had an advanced copy all
right sorry PS5 I think it was the new
PS5 game because it was only PS5 that
makes more sense in Earth 1610 actually
they're up to ps7 God damn it he's still
playing a retro game I don't feel like
this movie is too complex to answer the
question real quick in the chat for kids
I mean I feel like it sure it might be
but I feel like kids brains work off
Tick Tock now yeah so I feel like their
brains have been designed now to keep up
with a film like this 14 year old made
part of it Gabe de Costo um hey thank
you again Gabe hey
just for you Gabe
I mean you yeah cumulatively it works
uh spring
I didn't know I didn't know
also I love the album Metro booming did
great but nothing can top sunflower in
my opinion love you guys we love you
Flip Flip your face that is not a sexual
thing
um we're moving on now thank you I I
love uh this new album very much I don't
know which is my favorite because it's
too new and like there's something about
like digesting music love them both
Metro boom and killing it though Jonah
awk thank you Jonah Coy read it Jonah
aux Sony could use the excuse that
kingman's glider sent MCU vulture to
morbius instead of stranger spell I was
waiting for someone to bring this up
this fixes morbius y'all something
literally use the same villain that way
the end of morbius the post-credit scene
of him suddenly being in the universe
ties it into the live-action Universe
ties into morbius not knowing why ties
into a lot of the elements of certain
cameos not being in morbius but allowing
certain multiversal collisions without
it being an incursion event this not
only solves morbius but it solves some
of the elements that were plot holes in
the Venom tie-in at the end of no way
home this movie literally every single
issue people are complaining about Sony
like I said with the MCU look at the
macro wait for the things to come
together I guarantee you much like the
Kang Dynasty all of the issues where
people think things are in and out of
continuity Sony is solving the problems
with this movie and by the time we get
beyond the universe and Madam Webb it is
all going to be spelled out it's going
to be all accurate because they have a
10-year plan that I'm very excited about
so it it just it morbius is the best
movie in the camera
[Music]
it's a good Easter egg uh Brock's
venomint gum I I like yeah it was clever
I was I was here for that uh Ryan green
thank you you know why koi's suddenly
cooking so fast
you know why
I wanted to savor this because you often
have a jiffy it's a rarer occasion where
I am in the studio having fueled up a
kindness of Greg's heart G fuel so like
I'm I'm like the G and G fuel is
actually great it's always a treat for
me Greg Foo this is coffee this is G
fuel this is my third coffee and this is
water but you are drinking so many
diuretics
want to get a discount off G feel
there's a link in the description box
um ooh yeah next time koi starts to spit
I'm gonna I'll do a beat yay Ryan green
thank you thank you for contributing and
giving us something to talk about and
for your Good Vibes love the movie but
my main gripe with this movie is the
appearance between live action and
animated characters I got a bone to pick
yeah well animated ah Wise Guys will
animated characters stay animated when
they cross over to the other stuff like
the MCU I feel like this movie suggests
that they would stay animated simply
because I mean you got a live-action
Donald Glover the vulture comes through
as parchment and one world the Venom
world is live action and and clearly
like with vulture it is communicated
through dialogue like you you bring the
trappings of your Universe with you
she's like you're made of paper
parchment don't play with fire you know
yeah so I I I would beg some kind of
alternate explanation if they want to
start medium hopping I just don't think
it would work if you're watching a like
if you're watching Spider-Man 4 and then
animated miles comes into there I don't
think that'll work I've heavy with
who frame Roger Rabbit man that's gonna
be great I'm I think it's gonna I think
it's gonna work I honestly I think it
was really smart to like spoon feed us a
little bit because they had spot who is
arguably the most translatable character
to live action pop be the one that pops
in because if you think about the way we
perceive color uh some of the
discrepancy of seeing animated in a live
action is The Uncanny Valley is broken
right because there's certain color
elements and there's certain uh elements
of the eyes that reshape how you
perceive something so if you've got the
gas station attendant being the one that
first has the Animated World break in
spot literally doesn't have eyes the way
his colors are shaped none of that works
and when you look at animation like
cheaper animation you can always see
like if if I'm gonna pick this up in
animation there's a certain like outline
around it that has got to be different
so you get a character whose literally
power is a portal and if the portal is
the thing that you come through that
allows the portal to separate our eyes
from expecting anything to look
photorealistic and therefore you can
have an animated character in a
live-action world
down
field
[Laughter]
made it
Galaxy Geeks what's up good to see you
go check out their Channel they got
great reactions Carlos delamora
who could play miles in live action I
think shamique Moore can pull it off
um
you guys don't know
I love this he did Super Chat oh yeah I
can't wait what I think shamik or it can
pull it off uh in my opinion no one
knows because it's it's like the cloud
how does it
works
a white man can explain it pretty simply
who could play miles in live action I
think should meet more can pull it off
5pm thoughts love y'all I think that
would be pretty sweet if shamik Moore
man if they did just go it you
I would love a council of Reed situation
where there's multiple miles I don't
think the carry on
but I don't necessarily think 27 year
old should start the Journey of miles if
they're going to do a live action
Trilogy or more which miles deserves I
don't know if starting with shamique is
the move so I think there should be a
moment where we maybe meet a Multiverse
of miles and we see that he's not an
anomaly I think I think the closure of
beyond the spider verse would be really
beautiful if you find out that Miguel is
wrong because he's angry and that miles
is always deserving and miles is
supposed to be this thing and that he
self-actualizes in there is an element
of like no miles is Spider-Man because
he is anyone who can wear the mask would
be a full circle moment because he
deserves it so I'd love if Miguel is
wrong and there are more miles and I'd
love if shimmy gets to play him in brief
but I don't know if he should be the
long ongoing because then like you need
a 10 years older Peter Parker or more so
I just I think it puts us in a tricky
position age-wise but I would love to
see it what about Kayla McLaughlin uh I
think Caleb McLaughlin is a very
talented actor that is way more
multifaceted than people see but there's
a Latino element to the character that
is really important that I don't know
it's gonna be a hard cast because those
are two halves that are both vital to
the character so finding someone that is
those things I think it's easy from the
outside yeah to see Miles Morales and go
black Spider-Man but yeah I think you're
absolutely right it needs the the
Multicultural aspect seems intrinsic
what about Denzel Washington I mean or
Samuel Jackson yeah
guys with makeup you can make Denzel 15.
yeah yeah yeah King Kong I got nothing
on Miles Morales
[Applause]
oh I've never seen Training Day
what yeah whoa why is that not on the
list yeah that is the top now huh I
think it's unless I uh if it's not it's
we've talked about it so much on my
lists guys stop calling it equilibrium
equalizer off camera he's calling it
equilibrium so many times this is your
uh ready or not I I like I can't get the
movie tied that's the one time I've not
called it hide and seek so that's that's
yours
uh Matthew Kilburn aka Mr Mr Nakamoto
I'm gonna go with that that's a 20.
[Music]
Super Chat
I waited that time good thing I know
sign language my ears haha let's do our
first spectacular drop oh I'm so sorry
thank you that was when it was at full
volume thank you for the Super Chat my
friend thank you so much that's so funny
pizza boy 153.
koi always love hearing your thoughts do
you think that Deadpool 3 being a
Multiverse story and his relationship
with Spider-Man that we get a cameo in
part three I certainly hope so I think
they should put Deadpool in the animated
movie like get him give Ryan Reynolds a
cameo I think it's gonna happen do you
know what that would also do
tie into Donald Glover who was supposed
to make an animated Deadpool movie that
was canceled during the merger of
everything coming together without
another level of metamodernism that
would allow Donald Glover be another
facet of the world that allows us to
reference the fact that Donald Glover is
the reason we have this cascading event
of Pop Culture look it's like the audio
from the movie
trumps
and you can't hear you can't hear him
what's going on why can't I hear the
dialogue
I do think uh Spider-Man uh being in
Deadpool 3 is more likely now because of
this and I also think that the
culmination of phase five and six of
Marvel this impacts this is this is a
big shift and Deadpool 3 is going to be
the I think I think Apple three is gonna
be the live-action version of this where
it's going to be cleaning up timelines
it's going to be them going like Canon
events like I think Deadpool 3 and this
are going to mirror each other more than
you expect Deadpool 3 is going to be
another installment in the this is what
Multiverse of Madness should have been
franchise and I can't wait all right
John look Lucas see you're right I'm
gonna read this Super Chat I'm gonna
you're gonna be the one who answered oh
cool okay all right happy Saturday
handsome boys from Kiana Chanel uh
Spider-Man was pure joy the animation
Styles the story The cameos everything
was perfect for me spider Punk was
easily my favorite John please I want
you to talk about your opinions on
spider Punk and also about the ultimate
conclusion that happens when he does
help miles in breaking out yeah yeah
absolutely uh way too woke all right he
should have gone along with the
authority that Miguel O'Hara was laying
down without questions anti-government
yeah Batman's fascist uh I I adored
spider Punk for multiple reasons I mean
just the animation style they brought
along with him I love Daniel kaluya
anyway and I thought his attitude and
his just abandon in the booth the voice
performance was beautiful I was hanging
on every line and I do love the sort of
I love that the joke of his character is
true to his character and follows
through in crucial moments so yeah when
you you've got the Palms thing which is
a great little learning moment it's a
great moment to endear you to him but
then as that debate is going down I
thought that was an awesome character
choice because of course this guy would
do that this guy would be like this
whole organization is getting a little
messed up and I'm not about
authoritarian organizations so yeah I'm
gonna help you escape I had a question
about how he he drops his uh watch
through the portal before he goes so I
guess he must have like made like a like
a makeshift jury rigged one but uh yeah
I loved the function that he served and
he's probably my my favorite character I
really like the animation of him too
because there was such a variety to him
and he and he even there's even
something about the way they animate him
that feels like he's going against the
grain of all the other Spider-Man and
they're just so handmade yeah yeah like
it's just not as smooth as everyone else
and I think that's a really smart choice
yeah I love the attention yeah it's like
even his resting shapes and outlines
change yeah yeah Jay Colby P
um thank you so much this movie in
Guardians 3 show that Superhero fatigue
is a myth just wait till the Flash and
everyone's sick of it yeah
I mean I think there are people just
want great movies to tell a compelling
story that is true I I think the Saving
Grace uh for Flash really quick because
a lot of us were talking about it
because it's so obvious when you see you
know spider-verse and you're seeing what
the flash is all about that you're like
two Multiverse movies in the same month
one from the Marvel camp and the other
one from the DC camp and you feel like
you're probably going to end up
comparing them to some extent and
spider-verse you kind of walk out going
honestly how you could top it yeah
difference though that'll allow for
viewing experience like yeah it'll feel
different ultimately and one's a DC
movie and a live action movie but there
is that part of me that's like
I'm wondering if the flash is sort of
wishing that it came out before this
movie I've been thinking that a lot
because I have we are the only ones who
have not seen on the entire internet
everyone else
three times four times yeah I've been
hunting to try to get into I've said so
many emails and uh yeah we're the only
ones who have not been able to see it
everyone else we know it's a complete
reaction maybe Saturday well and two
hearing about these two movies
everyone's we gotta react to your
video George sorry people's been gushing
over spider-verse and then I've heard
you know all there's always that you
know like Oh The Flash is amazing but I
have heard people say like it's not like
the best it's really good though so I I
do feel like there may be that drop also
just want to shout out Shane Rose was
was Metro boomin's voice Cameo the
Spider-Man who's like upside down in the
black and white who's like there's
nowhere for you to go and then he's like
oh I guess there was yeah yeah that's
Metro Boomer which I love doesn't came
here that's so cool I didn't realize the
second time I saw it I was like which
design is this and who is that voice
because I bet it's a cameo yeah all
right guys
due to the time I'm gonna start making
sure we stick a little we're gonna be a
little bit more
pedantic with our timing here okay
all right Google chesticulate because I
used it yep all right
so here we go j03 j3 r k off Joe jerkoff
no yeah no one would say that all right
don't Joe
spot had a great origin but I kind of
wish his motives weren't I'm Mr evil man
and wants to rule the Multiverse because
we're intertwined miles
why not I didn't think he had that
motivation I thought yeah he's a little
deeper than that he was also really uh
scorned too I mean the guys had
a like a tear I love that they leaned so
much into he's lost so much especially
by what he has morphed into like
physically like he loses he loses touch
his whole body is like bodied figure
it's a body horror tale with him yeah
you know it's an inverted version of
what miles is going through too because
he's like he doesn't belong anywhere and
is you know sort of being discarded and
overlooked and all sorts of other things
and his going against all the Canon
rules in spite of that he's also got
such an isolated life because he's from
like a future timeline when things went
wrong so I I didn't feel like he was Mr
evil at all I thought it was a very
Justified reason to feel that way Joseph
Taylor thank you koi read it what
possible conclusion would ruin the third
film uh I mean I think if they made it
uh a very linear tale that sacrificed
all the Nuance of like the first movie
is basically telling the story of
quantum theory and making it digestible
the second is telling the story of what
Canon is and making that digestible if
the third film is just a wrap up instead
of introducing new ideas or not
introducing new characters and all those
things that would feel like I got
shortchanged but short of that I I'm not
worried about the third film
I'm not worried about it at all I think
it's going to be amazing we're gonna cry
in the theaters a lot
we've got I was kind of kind of like the
Multiverse hasn't really been exciting
as much as we all hope within the MCU
right but that's it's one movie just
like completely changes the game the FCU
has simply been here to push all the
other Multiverse movies along yeah
everything Spider-Man all at once was
the perfect answer to that and I also
think that we are looking at things too
small because it's it's a big Multiverse
Saga so this this just helps people have
faith again Joseph Taylor John please
Joseph
uh Azelia Azalea
I saw this
thank you by the way for being here in
4dx and it was the perfect experience I
believe that would be maybe overwhelming
but also quite fun I feel like this
would be a fun 40x I would be totally
down to season 40x I got tickets to see
it I got tickets for Oppenheimer like
two weeks after its release this is just
to go against Tom Cruise and uh
it's all sold out it's so it's
sold out it's so sold out driver I'm
like Jesus I'm on the last day and it's
like it's an R-rated movie selling that
hard it's crazy and I I would that is a
fascinating topic over there I I could
totally fathom Tom Cruise being upset
he's like a cliff for the
motorcycle
this is his hateful eight oh totally
yeah no and he he has been I mean
from the director's side Nolan has been
uh such a champion for proprietor of
IMAX influence within just modern Cinema
and Tom Cruise has been the star-making
vehicle
yeah so it is interesting to see them at
odds with with their films because yeah
I mean like someone is the records Tom
Cruise is the starter they're both IMAX
lovers I bet Tom Cruise where she hadn't
seen tenant in the lockdown now yeah
Millie's Dana forces Oppenheimer and 40
and you literally get nuked
it's just a bunch of charts skeletons at
the end of the show uh Jay Colby paid
one more thing and funny thought I had
Greek I know you're already people
throughout the movie I was I'm thinking
about their song parallel universe off
of Californication fitting the movie oh
my God so happy we already got can't
stop in Black Panther wakanda forever uh
I would absolutely love it if we did get
parallel universe in there or under the
bridge and it doesn't fit at all
it's just because miles is walking under
a bridge yeah
oh my god get guito Lindo everyone be
quiet everyone be quiet
that means you
[Music]
for us it's a moment of silence that
doesn't generate any of the energy
because we can't hear it yeah it's just
peace so weird
watched it last night uh uh uh you
watched last night at Regal in qns not
sure where that is but I'm I'm excited
uh sound was bad didn't matter I love it
watching it again animation was
Perfection is this setting the bar too
high for Spider-Man live actions love
you guys thank you for everything no
it's not the bar too high for whatever
the animated shows are going to be yeah
I mean it set the bars High boy I feel
like no way home gets a lot of crap
because it uses uh characters in a live
action setting that people consider
nostalgic if you actually look at the
writing of no way home it has so much
going on so I feel like the the live
action bar is like high because of no
way home but that's my experience in
these films they're very different but
it's miles of California
sorry I was listening also I look at
them differently also qns is Queens so
yeah freaking Queens for this awesome oh
that makes me happy beautiful
beautiful git though John please take it
away Amanda we love you thank you for
being here a real rejects much love for
y'all spider-punk was great and exactly
how I want Anarchist Spider-Man to be
loved the Donald Glover uh Prowler Cameo
there we go and want to see more Prowler
and Miles he uh Prowler miles I should
say he was intense he was dude so
um
John what do you think the lesson will
be for miles from encountering Prowler
miles what do you think the LA there's
there's one thing that I love about
these films is there's always they lean
into the themes to advance their plot so
what do you think the character journey
of our miles encountering this miles is
ultimately going to lead to
um that's an excellent question and I am
I am all honestly I've been wondering
about this because it is brain moving
yeah that's why I looked at John first
I've been wondering about this because
there's so much about miles's Journey
that you know just kind of happened to
him that wasn't about his choice in the
matter necessarily I mean certainly he's
inserting himself and what Miguel says
about like you know so much of this is
your fault like I I get that at the same
time you know obviously there's going to
be some kind of you know this is what
could have happened you know this is I
guess it's like the bigger version of
I don't know yeah it's personifying that
fault it's like you know in order for
you to have this spectacular life you
know a different version of you suffers
greatly and that's speaking to the
balance of I guess the universe the
Multiverse Etc but I feel like uh koi
would probably have a deeper Insight
Comics related
I do feel like the use of the Cameo also
ties into the idea that basically if you
things go wrong things go bad and the
fact that they didn't cast Donald Glover
is Spider-Man and him turning into the
prowler is kind of a beautiful metaphor
of like he didn't make me Spider-Man's
now I'm a bad guy so I love the idea
that the movie's ending reflects that so
when he doesn't become Spider-Man he
becomes the prowler which ties into
foreshadowing using Donald Glover as the
live-action cameo in the first place so
I do think there's going to be a
commentary on basically if you don't
have a mentor figure in your life to
guide you if you don't have your Uncle
Ben death if you don't have your uncle
Aaron death if you don't have that Canon
event it shows how things can go bad so
right now in our universe miles is
fighting for the idea that I have to
save everyone this is again the trolley
problem if I don't save everyone this is
going to help this is going to be a net
positive but if I do save everyone then
this is going to be great for me which
is almost a selfish concept so I think
what the third movie's metaphor is going
to be is basically yes there are
sacrifices to be Spider-Man with great
power there must also come great
responsibility the action of loss is
what drives you to be a better person so
when you don't lose the person if you
don't actually go through the way things
are meant to be things can go bad I
don't believe in destiny I don't believe
in fate but there are actions that have
consequences so much like the Don Glover
cameo in real life reflecting he didn't
become Spider-Man so he became the
prowler I think in the universe miles
has to learn that yes there must be laws
to achieve greatness
absolute vodka
and the idea that yeah like
so I don't think he saves uh I think
people have to die sure
I'm not focused on what I'm doing here
totally pay attention to you
Dragon Soldier thank you Dragon Soldier
uh
uh Storage Wars yeah that's right so
it's just me or during the train fight
with Miles versus Miguel look like they
were glitching into live action actors
with every fifth frame that is a very
specific catch that's a very I mean it
might have just been the uncanniness of
the fact that they of their humanistic
qualities and but they're animated I
thought that fight was
so wildly intense what's great what was
surprising to me was how much the trade
especially when I was editing the review
I was like damn you know the trailer
really did show you like kind of a lot
yet when you watch the movie I'm like
but this movie's still full of so many
surprise yeah like from beginning to end
it really is but the trailer does
essentially show you the the plot
mechanics of eventually leading to that
in The Showdown with with Miguel O'Hara
and then being at odds but there's a lot
of details they leave out in the
trailers of what leads you to these
events uh but I thought those those
sequences were breathtaking there was
nothing more thrilling to me than Miles
having to outsmart and having to escape
from a ton of spider people totally
there was nothing more exciting to me
than that like we've plain and simple
just haven't seen that any Spider-Man
movies of him have other than you know
Spider-Man versus Venom and Spider-Man 3
brilliant film by the way and exactly
the feeling that is generated here or
gesticulated here
but it is that but that was such a
beautiful sequence and to me heart
pounding I was on the edge of my seat
even though I knew the scene was coming
specifically with him and Miguel having
a showdown but my brain didn't prepare
me for a he's gonna have to like
maneuver his way through all of
them yeah that was beautiful I love that
it parallel the first film in that the
first film at a train going like
laterally right we never really saw it
Ascend it was it was a train that was
moving as trains do it was a train that
was going through the X and Y axis of
reality it was a train this way but I
love that in this one it allowed the
z-axis to be implied because the train
was ascending so I I pictured it as the
first films about The Multiverse in a
contained area but this film is about
like stacking the Multiverse so things
are happening simultaneously because
2099 would allow the timeline to be at
all times right like the everything
everywhere all at once so 299 is
happening parallel to 2002 Spider-Man
happening parallel to 2010 Spider-Man
with Garfield and Toby stacked so I love
that the train metaphor in the first
film is doubled down on this one by
having the train go vertically through
the z-axis in its own way
true true that
um okay we talked about this at the very
very beginning of the stream uh but uh
John why don't you answer that what was
your reaction
zadie is asking thank you so much uh
what was your reaction to find out that
Miles wasn't supposed to be Spider-Man
yeah I mean that that hits I think hard
especially when Miguel just lays it out
and you're like oh yeah I can see how
this Domino has really affected a lot of
things and you could argue like yeah
it's it's happenstance it's not your
fault but at the same time it is like
you were in like a really bad place at
the right time I guess you know because
of all this and it is like a conflicting
thing and it makes me excited to see how
they unpack that with the whole miles
Prowler thing because I mean yeah there
is like a compliment to that but there
is also so much that is just sort of
like random and if they hadn't been at
the collider and all that stuff that he
lays out like I thought it was a really
beautiful way to use the first movie in
a way that it's one of those things I
think it's always good when you're
sitting there watching this the sequel
and you're going today was this like the
plan from the start because like this
tracks and grows out of that so well
um and yeah I think it it really gave me
this feeling like of miles is kind of
alone amidst all these spider people you
know and I think that's a very unique
thing to be able to communicate because
there's always something that others a
Spider-Man and especially with the way
Gwen and Peter B Parker look upon him
this it's almost like there's a pitiful
look that they give him that he does not
want you know yeah it's like it's like
they know he's got a terminal illness
and they don't know how to deal with it
or something yeah yeah uh Diego guevera
Thank you so much uh thoughts on Gwen
being trans with symbolism of acceptance
of her spider Persona and her dad plus
the colors of her world and flag Easter
eggs well we have talked about it and I
think it's used nicely uh I don't feel
like
uh that someone I think someone was just
saying it in the chat I'm processing a
lot of information right now uh but that
I think people ultimately don't actually
even the ones who like
about world culture all the time uh like
just I'm not saying they're about
actual wolf culture I'm saying what in
quotes what they just like the you know
the keywords virtue signaling identity
politics well culture I think at the end
of the day we actually don't have a pro
a lot of people don't have an issue with
that I think what they have an issue
with is if they feel like it's in some
way being like disingenuous being forced
into their way when a lot of times I
don't feel like it is uh personally it's
sometimes something comes first but I
think sometimes there's subtle things
like that where you could totally miss
it
even
but it's still there and that's what we
were trying to talk about earlier was
that a lot of times when it's being
described of what people are mad about
we're we're in the camp of go you guys
get what I'm trying to say with this I
want to make sure yeah um I I understand
what you're saying yeah what I'm trying
to say is that what they get mad about
because I've been seeing it's been going
on with the chat this entire time we've
been talking since we've brought it up
uh what we get annoyed at is the fact
that no the same kind of context is
still here and we're not trying to say
it just doesn't feel like left-handed
we're not yeah it does not feel
heavy-handed it's actually done really
well but it's still it's still so much
lace throughout the film and to say that
those things are not in this movie
would be false they're they're totally
in this movie and I think it's really
cool how it's a little bit more overt
than a lot of the things a lot of the
properties that people actually get
upset at it's way more over they
literally have like blm's lives yet
people are still so on board with this
movie I think it's because it feels real
like you're saying like it feels it
feels like what our world is like I
think that when you see a certain movie
and you change everything it feels like
a lot when it's like uh actually Taiko
matidi just had a quote about this where
it's like I never had a group of friends
that was one of each cult if there's
seven people and like there's literally
a token of each culture like a like a
Captain Planet that can feel
heavy-handed but like if you've got like
seven Polynesian kids and a Polynesian
story that feels beautifully
representative so I think like our world
is I don't know that the character is
trans but her support I don't think
she's trans right so I just want to
clarify that but I would argue like I
support trans kids I support trans lives
I support trans people I'm not trans but
I love that that is something that her
and her dad
Port vocally so it feels more real than
it being like hey we gotta discuss this
it's just a part of her bedroom it's a
part of his uh wardrobe and that feels
more natural to me and I think that's
why people aren't up in arms because
that's art world you should support
people you should support progress you
should support everyone and care about
everyone so the lighting is beautiful
the the elements of it are beautiful
because it feels like our reality where
loving someone is how it should be not
something that should be noticed what's
funny to me though is
remember the the Blue Beetle thing where
George Lopez's line a character we don't
know who the hell he is like we don't
know who that care what's his name like
tell me everything about that character
yeah you don't really know that most
people don't know who this person is and
he has one line in there about Batman's
a fashion so that through a certain game
people assume that is the whole movie
yeah and then there's so and it's
obviously some like stupid joke
the the the then you got spider pumpkin
here who has a lot of these lines and
yet no one's upset about it and I'm not
saying people should be upset I just
find the the uh I find humor in the fact
that no one's upset well yeah because
it's just part of the character and that
really reads it's not a character it's
not a message disguised as a character
so it makes it so I wonder what if those
lines were in the trailer
I didn't miss that I didn't catch that
oh yeah I saw in the first trailer
because I was very like oh they put this
in in this to show people where they
stand and I like that to the chat it
doesn't really matter if Gwen is trans
or not yeah we're saying we haven't been
told it but it doesn't seems as if she's
not or she I don't know she could be
non-body wherever but it doesn't really
matter if she is or isn't yeah just like
in our universe yeah that's what I'm
saying clearly she's down for the cut
she's in a punk band yeah
yeah not to stereotype all Palm I'm sure
there are some intolerant punks out
there but
you know because I it's it is funny to
me what has happened with the word uh
what has happened with the idea of what
woke culture is when really it's lost
sight of what its original meaning was
and it's become a bunch of things that
other people have like labeled it as now
yeah and a negative connotation is just
opening your eyes to the systematic
injustices of the world and being aware
of how to move despite them my favorite
is about white woman it is no white
women have done all of the legwork it's
about it's about it's about female leads
and movies that's right and making every
white character black or Asian
laughs
Diego we got you
it's like it's not the main takeaway of
the movie but it's becoming a topic of
conversation that's what's so funny
about it is it becoming a topic of
conversation
I love it I love it hey conversations
are good uh I personally it's Thai girl
thought it was better than the first
movie but that's insane because the
first one's like a 9 8 is like a nine
nine they're both insanely see play
Bland Dizzy's bring up a good point
where I actually feel like spot could
have a change of heart sure oh yeah
it seems like they're setting him up for
being like the most ultimate villain
which which yeah there's a very big
likelihood that that could happen at the
same time I could see it going down the
like an auto octave or the mini
Spider-Man do you have those villains
yeah I could completely see because like
who the hell's gonna stop him right like
how do you stop this guy only Spock can
stop himself you know yeah and what if
he's an element that helps them navigate
the web of life like it'd be so cool if
like his interdimensional yeah he's
become a positive he becomes yeah like a
crucial part of keeping all the
continuities intact exactly which would
be cool it's right there
[Music]
big respect to the spot Great Character
yeah I'm really impressed by that
villain and good job for Jason
Schwartzman doing the voice yeah liked
his Vibe Nicholas Cage's cousin
Spider-Man noir's cousin spot which is
funny because they're both black and
white that was so sad when they said he
wouldn't be back for spider Noir and yet
you know they they made me happy by the
end it was good
I mean maybe it's a different voice all
right we got some uh we got some
streamlabs we got to make sure we get
through sales all right Garth Harkness
McMurray we're 30 minutes behind here oh
a lot longer than that what okay it's
from may 20. we have some other ones no
no we're gonna read the May 20th ones
there you go no Chanel is the first one
for today
oh God
oh oh oh man oh god oh man oh god oh man
no Chanel thank you so much my dear
haven't seen it yet so just supporting
from afar oh kind beautiful beautiful
woman thanks for letting us spoil the
movie for you I hope you listen to the
whole thing yes front to back thank you
no Chanel Luna Luna hi y'all you all
look beautiful
stop it yeah
you look I'm amazing fine stop
it did y'all like this soundtrack more
than the last
I need to revisit I don't know
I I certainly kind of I've messed this
up hold on a second John John please
now it's perfect
listed more than the last uh this this
one like it grabbed me the soundtrack
not to say that like it did might not
have the first time but I haven't had as
much of like a I I associate sunflower
with the first movie whereas this one I
I kind of felt the whole soundscape so
I'm kind of leaning to this one but it
might just be recently biased terrific
either way yeah
also just in the vein of this go listen
to the Attack the Block soundtrack that
basement Jax did also the score for this
by Daniel Pemberton is like incredible
oh sure absolutely respect
to the pemb all right here we go
um
where are we at we are dust
hey
first time donating to anyone well and
I'm sorry I'm not doing a lot it's okay
then we're moving on moving on that's a
that's a dollar's worth of a read oh
thank you yeah anyways did you guys see
that apparently it took three years for
them to develop the art style of spider
punk I think it took four for the
original art style correct me if any of
this is incorrect I uh I mean I would
certainly believe it and I would love to
see more behind the scenes like you
assume everything in the movie like this
is created on a computer however you do
have like a I could tell the first time
we saw it like the Lego this is not CG
Legos these are real Legos so I I would
be very curious if there was any actual
collage or Pastiche if this movie only
cost a hundred million I don't
understand because how do other movies
cost 200 million and this one costs 100
like animated movies wild it is
mind-blowing the fact that it's gonna
make all of its money back opening
weekend and then just go on to profit
I'm so happy it's probably because they
don't use super expensive voice-over
actors yeah but even the visuals like
neither does Pixar and Pixar movies cost
like 200 million dollars it is
interesting and I mean I I wonder
it's the kind of Animation that really
makes me wonder because they do leave
like I love that the look of the spot
you can literally see the circles like
the guidelines and the early parts of
Animation so they're aspects of the
animation style that look like
unfinished or hand-drawn and yet I sit
there going does that take less time or
does that take deceptively more time to
accurately do it so yeah I am a little
mind blown yeah because the art style is
so many things and is like every frame
looks like it must take so much time and
care and they also hired uh in talking
to the
Philip Lord they hired comic book
artists as consultants so the art that
you love from the comics or I love from
the comics if you read Comics they
brought them on to help the animators
draw in their style that is something
unique to this movie and also cannot be
cheap yep yep cannot all good oh good
the wobbler do you guys think the
inheritors
are going to come into play in The
Animated Universe or do you think they
might save it for the live action movies
I think that's for me uh I think the
inheritors and Moreland and characters
like that are gonna stay unique to the
comic books I don't think they're gonna
be live action or here I think the
inheritors are uh more beneficial for
the medium of comics because they're
almost like vampiric they feed off the
life force and things and there's a lot
of things they haven't introduced yet
that I don't think they will the the
idea of a spider totem the idea of a lot
of the animal elements in the comic
books uh Peter Parker Spider-Man is
attached to this thing called the spider
totem and that's why he fights a lot of
animal-based villains like Rhino vulture
all those elements they haven't
introduced anything akin to that here
and I don't think they necessarily will
so the idea of the inheritors taking the
life force of these animal totems
doesn't really tie in that'd be a lot to
really tie into a third film so I don't
see a live-action spider verse working I
don't really see an inheritor totem
element working but that's the beauty of
this candid event all these universes
are unique to themselves so it all still
works in that Medium
bogey
I agree definitely distracted by what's
going on in the chat
it's just the fact that the you know are
we still on bigotry the woke Wars yeah
and we're gonna solve it today normally
I'm doing what you're doing
not busy there's a reason you're not
banned dude
you're good you're good busy oh yeah
this is great yeah was it brown downtown
it's just your name's busy and I saw a
chance to say busy busy busy
because it just it worked there man
absolutely this is the fight
unless you become a total ass the white
man speaks gibberish is my favorite
comment we have deaf we have definitely
banned people we will do it again if we
must
but so far I have it's so if someone
sees someone really crossing the line
please let me know but uh the real
Antonio is 50 Cents I ain't talk fast
you just gotta listen a little faster
olenti I watch the NR breakdown okay
and Eric points out a part where the
miles parlor variant is about to be
bitten by the 42 spider
I did see I did hear about that like
there that Miles that Miles was supposed
the prowler one he was supposed to be
the Spider-Man right like that that was
where it belonged so if he was going to
be Spider-Man his universe doesn't that
negate miles being an anomaly love this
no what did Gates it is that the miles
in the or whichever which are the smile
16. okay yeah that miles is the one that
was not supposed to be a Spider-Man
that's where the anomaly comes in yeah
and he hijacked the other ones and
because our universe it was supposed to
be a Peter and in the 1610 it was
supposed to be a Peter Parker yeah yeah
that's supposed to be Chris Chris Pine
but appreciate the question here thank
you Chris Peter Pine uh I loved spots so
much I think that's a it's rare we could
get a villain who could go like that
goofy to truly terrifying such good work
yeah I was gonna say uh uh to you in the
chat there Miguel O'Hara I think Goofy
and menacing in a way that really worked
yeah yeah
hold on guys
uh-oh we got we got a desktop
hold on I done messed up everything here
what have you done where'd it go John oh
it's in another window uh go up to the
top just like move the mouse up to the
top uh okay never mind
and uh right click this you're foolish
yeah I found it John I fixed it well
done no help whatsoever alrighty here we
go where are we at Jim Carrey would be a
fantastic spot well let me refresh this
oh man what a what a beautiful beautiful
thing that would be what time are we at
it's currently 2 27 p.m we got three
minutes here to not to enter to get it
through everything
all right sorry
guys yeah I want to go to Africa oh
let's do it my wife no not with you guys
yeah yeah Cape Town we haven't had a
honeymoon dude uh I got some places to
recommend you in Cape Town have you been
in Africa yeah I was there five weeks I
went to uh Africa burn I went to Cape
Town I went to there's like a beautiful
tabletop Mountain Justice yeah I love I
love Africa I have not been to Africa I
want to go and there's some like really
unique food I ate Springbok on pizza and
it was really delicious wow yeah I love
Africa it's a really pretty place
there's like human rights out there do
you think um
do you think uh
The Lion King place are there do you
like The Lion King oh no it's actually
just uh you walk out and animals are
doing it it's just yeah yeah that's why
it's not Appropriations because the
animals just do them The Lion King is
performed you know like six or seven
times a day and uh also you can just
take a walking tour of District nine
it's all there all right count it let's
see where we're at in a couple minutes
here
[Music]
sorry I read the rule 34 comments you
did you got close all righty okay so
let's let's recap everything that we
have definitely talked about in the
Stream
ending
favorite cameos most talked about
insomniac
spectacular spectacular Donald Glover
Donnie Gwen
uh the parents spot yeah okay we've
covered most of the Bing with Multiverse
Multiverse we've got to cover Peter B
Parker that much he was great the like
the main part okay yeah then I will find
a way because sometimes I try to find a
way to go what is the topic we have
talked about and how to segue it into
one of the series I think that's the
only element I can think of uh let's go
here let's go here
ah what is busy Brown's profile pic I I
don't I know this
I can't tell I can't tell it's got a
white hat I mean is it you or is it
somebody famous
I don't know or is it just a stock photo
of someone who's not you okay ramen
noodles I'm at Yuri 12 years ago Diablo
four servers are down that's messed up
I want to play Diablo all right here we
go we're gonna do this good just good
Malik Curry
I think some way miles is introduced
prior to Secret Wars and during the
secret Wars event they kill off Tom thus
passing the torch to Miles how
awesome would it be if they just killed
off Tom Holland oh I would love it how
upsetting would everyone can you imagine
the audience responses killing off Tom
Holland I think Spider-Man is something
Tom Holland loves but I think there will
be a time when he is like I'm done with
Spider-Man and I think the best way to
bring in a certain character is to kill
off a beloved Spider-Man I still think
they're probably going to kill off
Andrew Garfield but I really think uh I
really think that Tom would be a very
impactful death you really believe that
they're still going to bring back Andrew
Garfield in some way yeah
I don't see it
I think we're gonna get a Spider-Man 4
and an Amazing Spider-Man 3 in some way
whether that's in secret ores as a long
they should just like combine them
I believe just two movies
just combined finally directed by saying
how cool would it be if they just had a
movie where it was just Andrew Garfield
and Toby just like Lethal Weapon but
it's like the Spiderman yeah how great
would that be lethal spiders
how cool would it be man I mean I I just
want them to get their closure they got
a lot of closure at no way home but I do
think we get I think it'd be really
interesting to have venom lines but Tom
Hardy fighting Andrew Garfield and maybe
him dying in that Miles coming through
that Universe I don't feel like they
kill off Andrew Garfield there's too
much money to be made I don't feel like
Andrew Garfield wants to do it a lot
longer because if he talked about being
a 40 year old in spandex I know he
looked great he did I'm very I mean
great dying Andrew all right here we go
okay
um yeah that's true no I don't think
they're gonna kill off Tom Holland Tom
Holland should play him for years to
come he doesn't have anything his newest
movie got some rougher come on guys
consistently seriously what does Tom
Holland have outside of spider Uncharted
who is truly a massive hit Zendaya she's
doing better than him nobody I think he
wants to like go have like a family I
think he wants to just go like I think
he wants to have a fan I think he's a
very talented actor I think a lot of his
work outside of Spider-Man is great and
and I but I think you know that's what
sometimes keeps people there yeah these
things are like I'm not really having
anything outside yeah it's not really
puffing off for me you know I just want
Tom to be happy whoever that looks you
need that you need that I think yeah
that's hard to transcend a character
like this I mean how many of the
character that makes your name I mean
look at Robert Downey Jr what has he
really had since leaving Iron Man
Oppenheimer
that's why everyone wants to watch it
for Robert Downey Jr bald Robert Downey
Jr yeah yeah definitely
um let's go here
where are we at Dan tanvi yeah no yeah
yeah uh yeah yeah thanks John DMV 900
Earth 42's Jefferson is also named
Jefferson Morales rest in power Captain
Morales thank you dabby 900. it's his
name in multiple Universe Aaron Davis
keeps the name okay so I was just yeah I
was spitballing like maybe that'd be
unique but yeah Aaron Davis is
definitely because they're not married
but yeah I'd be interesting
thank you Dan v900 absolutely there
can't be uh answering your question
right now
we'll be back soon
we'll be right back to you Malik Curry
here we go uh we already did that yeah
we're Jorge Jorge this is uh this is a
really good question how did they keep
Glover Under Wraps without leaking that
scene was a stealer in my theater so
much history is in that one scene hey
Carly King is in the chat hey what up
what up Carly
go subscribe to all her stuff goes
follow her on everywhere like Coy does
obsessively watching her stuff every
moment of the day yeah
with the helmet
um
facts uh I think they shot it on a sound
stage and like it was a small set I
think you could sneak him in yeah I
think it was just a closed set it was
like five of them and uh I saw a picture
of the Wardrobe designer with him in the
suit and it's awesome to see the suit
like with good lighting and everything
else because they must have hidden all
of that so yeah when I make that Tick
Tock that's even deeper cut of what I
went through I'm gonna post that picture
because it's really beautiful because we
saw this at an early screening where uh
koi's best friends as mentioned earlier
Phil Ward and Chris Miller they did say
like hey you guys are like the first
people to see this so please don't do
any spoilers I was like all right yeah
I'm sure there's like a couple of cool
things in here
there's a lot of things happening these
are crazy cameos yeah yeah that's cool I
also think some of the benefit of the
movie being animated is it's not as
scrutinized as the live action movies so
there's less people like out there
trying to scoop so I feel like this
maybe being uh you know this 125 million
opening weekend surprised the same
people that weren't spying on it like a
Marvel movie and I think that was a huge
benefit it's very true one two the whole
thing is made in in you know big rooms
with computers instead of like oh this
actor was spotted here and oh there's a
set over here and you know like yeah
there's I think you can easily lock and
key and also people probably have a
little bit different of a kind of
respect for the animators that's a
thousand percent true okay damn v900
okay this is a good one really my this
is a uh a spectacular shout out everyone
be quiet
[Music]
Super Chat really my number one
criticism is Ben Reilly being an avatar
of the 90s the comedy worked but that
fit came more to me with a character
used like that I did enjoy Ben Reilly's
appearance here I'm not as much of his
Enthusiast as say him
um in fact I'm a bit surprised that you
seem very satisfied with how they
handled him where I felt like a lot of
people were very let even for me who's
like I'm not married to any part about
Ben Reilly even to me I'm like I thought
they'd do a little bit more with him so
other than like a couple of like funny
lines poking at him I I acknowledge the
90s are a tricky time for a lot of
people so I feel like he was much more
digestible to the people that like knew
him casually and you're trying to make
this movie for the audiences not for
people like me that's the issue is these
people that are upset about Ben Riley
are the die hards and I respect that you
want like more of a a story about Ben
Reilly's journey and I see the Kane
parallel you're talking about here sure
but Kane is violent and Ben Reilly isn't
so I thought the anguish being more like
emo and like going through that worked
for the character this is a guy who dyes
his hair blonde tries to start his own
life and goes through like PTSD moments
about who he is the linear way to tell
that is the simple way they did here I
would love more Ben Reilly my theory on
Ben Reilly is he is an existential
crisis of Peter Parker going through
like a midlife crisis about
responsibility I don't know if we'll
ever see that I would love that I know
Tom Hong also loves the clone saga maybe
one day but for now as an introduction
to the character I do think it worked
and I I think it still gave love to the
character especially in the style and
the art and everything else you make
sure to leave my brother's live stream
every single time every time alrighty
John this one's for you throwing it to
you John ooh doctor Father Figure here
we go so the question is John back again
do you think because miles stops
Spider-Man's Indie Spider-Man India's
Canon event that comes back to bite them
in Beyond maybe he's not as powerful it
absolutely could I mean they said they
don't always save these Dimensions as
they are uh you know being ripped apart
uh so I don't know there could be some
kind of last-ditch attempt to save it
I'm sure you know pravita is part of
their little team at the end so there
would be cause to go back but uh I don't
know I feel like we will see it again
because they need to resolve whether it
gets destroyed or not and I think that
could lead to some pretty big emotion
down the line I I mean I don't know what
it would do to pavita if it does go away
like would it you know like he's then a
spider out of time completely so can
they stabilize him forever it brings up
a lot of interesting questions well that
ties into my theory on why the Donald
Glover Cameo is amazing for 862 reasons
is that I think in the in the new
universe we have to acknowledge that
Miles hour miles 16 10 miles has to
accept that things have to go wrong for
good to happen and I think that likewise
Spider-Man India is not going to have
the responsibility he's reckless in that
Universe he's fun he's joyish but he
doesn't have the captain dying to shape
his responsibility and I think that's
going to be a factor absolutely you guys
are a hundred percent correct Laura Saya
uh Ben Reilly is the Andy Samberg voiced
one he's Scarlet Spider he's got like
the the hoodies yeah the big muscles and
the hoodie looking thing and he's uh one
of the three that goes to pursue miles
at the very end this wall looks fine
yeah this wall looks fine this is weird
I like across the spider verse more than
no way home Disney fan thank you for
always being here my friend uh let's see
here Chris Thomas do you think in the
third movie it will come out the Miguel
is the anomaly he's the only spider
person that has to drink something to
keep his powers ooh oh yeah he did good
good theory well he's got vampire
elements because of everything he's gone
through physically and the world he
lives in in Nueva York but it would be
very interesting if the reason he hates
miles so much is he is another so he
sees himself in miles and that causes
the animosity
hadn't even considered that like he's
like very projecting Eerie yeah ah he's
the one that's a problem and he's like
fixing his own problems like he's like
bandaging universes that he causes
issues or maybe there's some type of
thing about uh you know
two million it's like it's like a
Hancock thing oh yeah too many anomalies
yeah one room yeah
yeah uh
that old Hancock reference those come up
a lot dude man I'm always referencing
Hancock and this is the Pinnacle of
superhero films it's underrated
let it be known
come over to silence for Hancock uh
orko when Andrew Garfield thank you so
much uh saved MJ in no way home did he
technically disrupt a Canon event I
guess not I guess these Cannon events
and things that are supposed to happen
in TVA timelines and all those things
there's always the con if time travel
they constantly create questions or like
what is what is meant to happen what is
not meant to happen because this person
actually did the thing that you're
saying they're not supposed to do but
that's okay it's a constant just go with
the plot because they take place in the
same so what they're giving you because
they take place in the same movie I
think it's that May's death is the uh is
the Canon event for this and the lack of
Uncle Ben implies it's a different
Universe because of the Uncle Ben being
announced May uh parallel the Mary Jane
character is in most timelines supposed
to be the one he ends up with so I don't
think she's a Gwen uh stand in except
for in the moment that you know the
Green Goblin who's also not supposed to
be there causes the moment so I could
see it being like you know an incident
for a nod but not a Canon event yeah
yeah
it would be interesting if you know when
like in no way home when they brought
like the other characters over if they
implemented that glitch effect in the
live action if like that happens
that would be a way to I feel like
there's a consistency that you can do
with that you know what I mean because
uh special edition make it happen do it
man the more fun Edition yeah exactly
what we'll just said right there yeah
that's what I was saying the other
Peters don't glitch when there are no
way home and so if they did Implement
that hives ahead of the chat for once
Miguel does need the blade serum hell
yeah Chris uh Thomas no Frank DX my bad
Frank DX thank you the story plot pasted
the characters the animation is what
makes this movie so good you can't even
decide who's right Miguel or miles I
don't know round two chewing it that is
what I think huh round two tonight I
think you said oh no round two twoing it
yeah round two two
yeah
yeah that was I love a solid debate
especially in a Sci-Fi scenario of what
would you do it's you create a great
debate over something that is very
relatable that's very realistic this is
a very heightened science fiction
scenario here and that's why I
constantly go back to you know one of
the most best scripted debates totally
bad language there one of the best
scripted debates ever in cinema to me is
the scene with Dr Hammond and um Jeff
Goldblum in Jurassic Park of whether or
not they should have created the
dinosaurs that is one of the best
debates because this is a totally
science fiction scenario and it puts you
in the seat of yeah whose side am I on
here it's a big ethical debate and that
is exactly what I found they did here as
well like of course I'm invested in
miles and of course I would want
Jefferson to live but maybe Miguel has a
point I think that is one of the best
things about that's one of the things
that puts this above into the
spider-verse for me is creating that
complexity that makes you have to choose
and then even ending on a note of
I don't know is Miles being selfish
and the ethical conundrum of both we
know this will happen to this guy what
do we do and then that thing of yeah
like if you had no idea yeah it's like
the very fact that you gain the
knowledge screws up everything because
then yeah like do I do I just let this
go or do I intervene because now I have
to because I know about it and I love
the weight of the you know it's already
so much to bear for a Spider-Man when
they lose a captain or they lose an
uncle but there are some of these care
like Gwen who's just waiting for her dad
to die like that what that puts on a
character that that is one of the things
that I feel like makes this movie so
much darker yeah I know my dad's gonna
die and I'm kind of just waiting for it
to happen like this is how it has to be
well what happens now that he's quit
because do does that Universe just avoid
this entire like I feel like there's
something to that there's nothing
happening like how it happened in
Spider-Man India yeah there's no
cascading you know end of implosion yeah
but it seems like it happens naturally
in her universe so I feel like that
could be a detail that is part of the
result of Beyond in some way all right
here we go Frank uh DX also saying guys
by the way when are you guys watching
the flash we don't know we're the only
ones
[Music]
Andy bushetti subscribes hook it up but
I was trying to I've emailed so I've
gotten so many uh so many emails and
half the people in our lane I even tried
doing the whole like hey I actually did
the math and then we have the biggest
trailer reactions to the movie look uh
and Andy machete even followed us on
Instagram like come on
[Music]
I was saying I tried to go with like hey
here I've helped let me help again and
no
thanks Brian Alexander he respects me
yeah sure yeah some real Andrew Tate
mentality right there oh he likes you
wanna you want some pizza you want a
pizza yeah it's Batman's a fish I want
pizza was that right compared to Andrew
why I don't know it just felt like she
came to my mind because I was listening
to the BBC thing yesterday I was making
the thumbnail sex traffickers but
that's not that's what pizza yeah it's
like what are you talking about
entertain he's the motivational speaker
yeah
you know garbage people can have some
good philosophies though
I tell you I mean because we support the
r from the artist what art
that is a solid Point going yeah
do you think into the spider-verse would
be better with just
go right am I read then right
it's
I feel like there should be like a V
there
um which is Gwen Peter and miles
really hurt the movie for me and I'm
curious what you think I don't even
heard the movie at all don't they man I
love those characters they really
elevated it I mean yeah when Peter and
miles would be fun but I feel like part
of the point is to have all those other
characters although John Mulaney did
come out and say that portraying spider
pig is what did get him down the rabbit
hole of becoming a drug addict that's
true what
oh
it's all this why everything was going
fine until I stepped into that damn
Booth man why did I decide to be an
animated pig it ruined my life Richard
Lloyd we're gonna end this stream suit
so I'm gonna abuse this
Is
Not Gonna Take It Easy
to bring him down a notch this little
Super Lemon man
oh my God I haven't been updating this
properly
Richard Richards bask in your failure
with some jar four three four two okay I
need to turn off the super chats
I mean no no I'm gonna just turn off
um being able to submit super chats
right now we're just gonna never read
them again you guys got like five
seconds to do it yeah oh oh there goes
the slider there goes the slider boom
if you continue your fans will no longer
see super chess as a person's option and
you'll no longer earn revenue from it I
understand the implications
what a great language it's so aggressive
uh but you can still send super stickers
if you want to yeah send a 200 super
stick those are the implications and we
will play the sound effect like five
times crank it up it was at 200 volume
those stickers feel like get back to you
know get back
[Music]
koi is just a white Lewis
you are white oh my god oh that's so
good oh my God that is hilarious you are
the white Pena I will just catch up on
lots of lore bye Disney fan Winsome gyro
4342 do you guys think 90 Spidey voiced
by Christopher Daniel Barnes will make a
cameo and Beyond I do I think I thought
he already made it no he's not in it yet
I said they have more Spiderman oh my
God then they totally have to do it yeah
he comes in I think silk comes in I
think there are certain characters oh my
God yeah what about uh the Ultimate
Spider-Man from the the animated yeah
yeah and I think that'd be an also an
interesting conversation because in that
Universe Donald ever is Spider-Man which
ties into my again third movies when is
Italian spider that's what they they got
it they gotta hop into like the actual
movies yeah from those back then yeah
dude that thing they used to do where
they insert like you know yeah insert
the characters into that old footage I
think that would be amazing there's also
a live-action Spider-Man model from like
the cover of an Amazing Spider-Man like
176 or something I'd love to see if
there's like the guys in it like just as
a still like they did the 60s swinging
that would be funny yeah yeah totally
Wampa if we use the voice modulator
everyone will be modulated Mike 2021
thank you my friend am I the only one
what are you doing nothing
I'm looking at the modulators to see
what our options are am I the only one
who wants a Lego Spider-Man movie now I
can see it focusing on the comedy like
Lego Batman
key magic Lord and Miller did a Lego
Spider-Man movie all of a sudden I mean
wow I was trying to think of how to
describe this tone to people who hadn't
seen it and I'm like it it does feel
like uh the Lego Batman it felt oh damn
I forgot what the other movie was but
yeah it definitely has that Lego movie
Spirit to it and would lend itself
easily I'm gonna look up the box office
for uh across the spider verse I don't
know how much it's made it's doing great
dude it's tracking at like 113 opening
weekend which is insane Boogie
let's do a variety has to say they're
great Everyone likes variety everyone
loves 51 million which is bigger than
Mario damn Mario did okay I know and
Mario is the second coming of Cinema
that's true I mean he's such a big
character the first one got an Oscar
it's got great word of mouth I think
it's gonna have legs I think even with
The Flash coming out in two weeks it's a
different enough market I think this
movie's gonna be huge slash doesn't
knock it out of first place I think
flash is tracking lower than they expect
I think it'll get first place but I
think it won't be as big of a margin
guys from King's Highway thank you so
much
didn't like spiders
[Music]
that is a great point you know how
people have said that they um you know
went into a state of depression
um contemplated life because they saw
Avatar and they wish their world was
really like that I had never had a
feeling like that with Avatar not even
come remotely close I actually had that
feeling I wouldn't like come out
depressed I did come out I would watch
you going wow I wish I could live in
this world a little bit I wish I could
be in that world uh Spider the spider
verse this one specifically did that for
me no I'd just love to be yeah
experienced a a moment of Life rendered
through that art are we still on the
voiceover thing John no it's us we're
here uh the thing we wouldn't be able to
hear it if John changed it
I can guarantee we are normal right now
um because this is a minute behind that
that was when it was just everyone's
saying no I I did it for various it's
not on I can see it so uh we'll see now
I'm back
[Laughter]
anyway but yeah guys I just had to run
something like I wanna
thank you Daddy I do want to say that I
think the leap in animation from
anything to spider-verse was somehow
matched in the leap from into to this
because we've seen Puss in Boots Liz
mentioned we've seen uh oh it's okay
we've seen the Turtles trailer like
we've seen animation Styles mirror the
first one I think this leap is the first
time like Avatar I thought was beautiful
but it didn't make me
um as emotional as this there was
actually a moment I found myself crying
watching the spiderwin footage and I
didn't it wasn't tied to story it was
actually like Beauty and that's only
happened to me twice in life it was the
Grand Canyon and the Cliffs of more like
two things that are in real life so
staggeringly beautiful it caused me to
emote unwillingly and and this was like
the third this really affected me so the
the Spider-Man universe was so beautiful
it like caused involuntary and emotegasm
yeah it was wonderful that's beautiful
Corey sat with a big smile on his face
during Schindler's List in 12 Years a
Slave but cry it all throughout across
the spiders
oh yeah which would be a great watch I'm
sure yeah people who will love non-stop
talking koi
follow the Easter Eggs only
oh my God and you would you would have
the best rant afterwards the
duplicitousness of Hitler edits I I
would so love your reaction just to
watch the rant that follows it just
watch you verbally punch Nazis for 20
minutes I need to watch a sea suit for
verbal punching Nazis here we go here we
go uh yeah yeah the reaction to it sisu
got a reaction with Roxy killing Nazis
so I was like yeah I'm bringing the Jew
girl on what scroll down a little bit so
the people you can see the one we're
about to read didn't mean it's right
this guy from Kings Highway we've just
read that oh really with the foe eating
didn't we just read that what the
wait guys to re-watched it was and then
that's when I went to the whole Avatar
Spiel and like this was you were it's
you were focused
copy that Johnny Cash I have been
thoroughly straightened out why do you
drink too much and it hurts when you
vomit I wonder if that's how it feels
when they glitch
no
[Laughter]
uh but yeah the spins is very much like
what I imagine this feels like when you
drink so much that you're like near
blackout like the brown out plus spins I
I think that parallel looks Fair
um fair enough
I hate you people goodbye that's a call
back to an hour ago
but I appreciate you Christianity thank
you Christian appreciate you just the
same trash boat all right here we go
people
what are you doing nothing I didn't do a
thing you didn't say there's no video
evidence or anything
that's terrible it's not what it's for
John I like comedy but I don't like
being made a fool
you guys don't understand what being I
read the wrong one Spider-Man has always
been my favorite superhero I'm 20 now
and I love this film
I'm white I'm a man oh this one talk
about woke stuff I don't think so I feel
like he's just contributing this
information
and nothing about this film bother me we
are all people and should accept each
other trash boat but you spelled except
with an exe so I feel like excellent
to dish out I accept him accepting
us
uh yeah I know what's going on John I
appreciate it no I'm just happy the
trash boat has proven uh against me
there's a white man trash boat is not
let me know you are the furthest thing
from you're like a yacht you're not a
trash boat at all and that's the fun of
your name
I just love the way that's sound it
sounds like a weird white savior I'm a
white man and nothing about this bothers
me
I know it's not at all what you're
insane I'm just trying to I feel like
it's just funny in a you know my stupid
brain
that's my print make it a gym I am here
as a lights man I'm a white man and I
approve the inclusion and diversity in
this film that's how every real rejects
video featuring Koy or I will start
that's how we do all do you see animated
intros yeah prefacing white man approved
[Music]
Chad you guys don't understand what
being woke means oh here we go it's when
the narrative Canon has changed for
political agenda
this movie has no political agenda in
its narrative I think he's a supporter
sure I think he's actually this is a
time when you go wait a minute we don't
need to just argue
let's see sure
he gave twenty dollars I'll see what it
means how do we elicit this we'll see
what you gotta say
spider is scanning and it's played
for laughs
yeah
um I think some people are getting
confused on what we're trying to say
about like what we're specifically
making fun of so there's something
coming down to our communication on it I
feel like we're making fun of people
that don't know what woke means and that
is awareness and it's not anytime you
say the word a powder cake it's nice
it's not it's not just that okay we're
we're making fun of what people who
say what woke is and then don't realize
that the things they often complain
about are actually in this movie as well
and just don't see it because a lot of
the time it doesn't even come down to
they're not even complaining about the
usage of context they're just
complaining about the fact that the
context is there you know what I mean
and I'm saying the context is here they
have flat out it's it's pretty clear
than most movies that they complain
about and that's what we were kind of
making fun of so yeah I don't I don't
feel like this movie sacrifices
narrative Canon for political agenda nor
do I feel like a lot of the movies that
they complained about do that's kind of
what I'm yeah that's what I'm saying is
that it's not changed for political
agenda it just is aware of the world and
is speaking for people it's like people
see the Miss Marvel trailer
and the somehow they've talked it up to
this is a big political agenda well it
was like when I said that uh before the
trailer game dropped for Captain Marvel
in 14 hours a very weak-willed men are
gonna have a problem with spider
and I think they straddle the line with
spider or punk in a sense that like it
is funny
a lot of his uh points of view are
played with humor but I don't think
they're played as just solely jokes yeah
you know like they're true to him and I
don't think the movie belittles that
yeah I'm not a role model I've been a
runway model like there's jokes in it
but there's also an awareness of his
stance but yeah I think this person's uh
saying what we're saying but I I don't
think it's as clear-cut as it's like
when Loki said he's by like when it
pretty much made it clear he's bisexual
in the show yeah of Loki this one line
that had no effect on literally anything
and there were people who were like
identity put like YouTubers making
videos about it identity politics
Disney's agenda
yes
so that's that's my point of let's say
they should be upset I'm not saying I
just think it's funny that they come out
and say there's nothing in here that's
the part of that is or something like
Guardians of the Galaxy it's the same
way how about that like this is totally
unwoke and I'm like this whole movie has
very and more movies than ever anyone
gives them credit for all have agendas
and politics within them whether you
like it or not just a very apparent what
side of what woke thing is being front
and center is the thing that upsets them
sure which usually involves race
swapping or female lead right that's
usually what it is or or any like
overtly homosexual anything that's male
oriented certainly yeah man
Savannah identifies as bisexual you know
I totally I hate seeing I hate it
reminds me of me not myself
gay kissing on screen maybe you
shouldn't have anybody kiss on screen
that's all I'm saying where all the gay
folks out here like get these hetero
kisses out of my face
Tyrone's definitely obsessed about
woveness yeah that's hilarious I feel
like you just winding reviews
because man YouTube sounds like the
worst place Husker for Life 109. koi is
just white Louise ah yeah that's right I
love it dearly thank you oh my God I
totally Skip One I'm so sorry how could
I have skipped the most important one
bring it back no
[Music]
watch the spectacular Spider-Man
constantly as a kid if I see him on the
big screen made my life complete they
gave him like a real scene but a
beautiful that line was so impactful and
wonderful it was a real Scene It really
like featured him with like a full-on
angle I wasn't even sure if Yuri talked
yeah that was so quick and they gave him
a speech bubble and they gave him a text
bubble which made me happy though but
yeah no they gave him a full-on like
Spectacular Spider-Man love moment I
honestly think uh Spider-Man Insomniac
comes in the third one more I hope
that would be cool it'll be a full-on
character and then they'll they gotta
get both designs though that's what I'm
saying there's a whole multiversal
conversation to have about the change in
Peter's design oh that'd be so much fun
if they have both but Yuri voicing
himself and they make clone saga jokes
at like the different Spider-Man and
zombie games and then bring in the
Spider-Man meme like the poorly drawn
like uh like they did with Sanic oh I
would love that I love hearing it slip
knot to Keyshawn big fan from Philly
been a fan since 2016. what
thank you yeah dude I would love to go
to Philadelphia
it seems like a great place never been
I've had a Cheesesteak once though I
want to see I want to see the Rocky
Balboa statue
oh oh that's interesting he doesn't get
royalties from the existence of his
statue
I don't know
strike statue strike Michael Hobson
I want everyone to know that I was
joking about the
gay thing I don't know if the internet
understand subtext I
I love gay people for a reason
I've tried I've tried doing things with
koi many times sure
Coy refuses
I value our friendship too much yeah
because I won't cross the boundaries
he's like Greg we work together like
we're best friends that third level so
quit being a and take it out well
yeah and everybody knows that like if
you're married you have a wife or
whatever you still have one slot open
for a dude a literal slot yeah you can't
have any more ladies but you can have
one dude it's not acceptable you know
just like you're like oh we have my wife
hooked up with another girl a lot of
women don't say that about their
husbands hooking up with another guy
stay well if you are those your spirit
is often if you want to watch your
significant male other hook up with
another guy then comment
that's an interesting I just want to
know what what percentage of the chat is
in that Vibe you guys put some uh what
are those what are those what's the
purple symbol the the squash or the
eggplant eggplants yeah
some little drips
oh yeah
Cory needs to accept what's wrong now
I'm the monster you weren't homophobic
have you seen my standard you know you
know where I stand oh I know a lot of
things about you after you're standing
but I never thought I would ever hear I
saw a whole new side of you that day
it was good it was Illuminating that was
the raunchiest stand-up show across
multiple sets it's why I'm not invited
to New York Christian cut me from New
York that's why yeah it doesn't fit the
tone that he's trying to go for I
literally got like two risque stand up
that's I got I got canceled 90 of you
guys would not too strong watch these
YouTubers do stand up from the Christian
harloff Channel and I'm like half of
them are just talking about sex dolls I
do love sex oh now we're demonetized I
only said it after you said phenomenon
and it's a beautiful strange thing
Michael Hobson
we're pointing the Life Services
do you think two hours and 50 minutes
thank you Michael uh do you think we
will get the Ultimate Spider-Man and
that version of Miles Morales and across
the spider-verse part two
yes definitely what if we just didn't
get that Miles Prowler
he's just Donald Glover doesn't come
back but he's animated his miles it's
just like they struck the live action no
I think I think we're gonna have a lot
of different uh ones of that I think
we're gonna see Ultimate Spider-Man
maybe talk to uh Earth one 16 tens yeah
miles and I think it'll be an
interesting like you know it Donald
Glover plays both Prowler and Ultimate
Spider-Man as a means of like
accepting that you have to look because
because Donald Glover's Ultimate
Spider-Man had to accept loss because
his parents there's loss so I think
maybe Donald Glover is the mentor to uh
shamique Moore's miles in beyond the
spider person oh
what if that Miles Prowler is really not
bad
that'd be interesting because I mean in
the comic books Hobie Brown okay so in
in Peter Parker's Universe uh the 616
Universe Prowler is Hobie Brown uh Hobie
Brown there's a completely different
Prowler who is a guy that turns to Crime
out of like having to out of necessity
you may notice that spider Punk is Hobie
Brown so there's actually a Hobie bound
Prowler and a Hobie brown spider Punk so
it stands to reason that there are
Prowlers who are good true cool all
right we're gonna knock this out roads
of uh nope Michael hop yep did that
Rhodes and teal I love the movie did we
talk about the comparison of what if
Doctor Strange episode to the movie
um no I don't know why that would come
up
but sure yeah I think that that would be
cool though if they did get what if
Doctor Strange to be in there actually
work in this animation that would be
amazing and it would like work better
than the movie tried to have a dark but
it wasn't him yeah to collab with them
but yeah that would be incredible oh
yeah this guy's great yeah and that
would actually work beautifully because
because that we did get an alternate
evil strange that would allow that Pat
that would that would actually patch up
the Multiverse plot hole the same way it
patch the mortgage butthole I love that
great idea do it it's all about patching
up plot holes that's what we use it all
for these days
I love Haley Steinfeld gem
absolute Jam Peach of a school
just got uh done thank you Oz chimp
just got done watching the movie and I
love it as much as Miguel is right he
definitely went too hard on Miles yeah
really it's just his communication
issues Miguel needs to be a better
Communicator I love that people see
Miguel is Right miles is right because
that's a real like we talked about with
sci-fi a real like answer but also uh he
that's his character it makes sense what
he's went through that'd be that way and
like how we wouldn't respect that he has
to do this horrible thing he feels like
no one else is responsible but me he
even says like I'm the only one fixing
it he has a whole spider Society helping
him but he's like no it's just me so I
think it was perfect it's pretty cool
that Oscar Isaac is
our moon night and also
one of our Spiderman now yeah and
apocalypse guys
yeah
Redemption for Oscar Isaac
you guys can't see but I just lowered
John's mic
so many things about nevermind gal is
racially motivated
sure no
Puerto Ricans in my spider verse oh my
God
oh my god oh we got a 20.
[Music]
James wheeler hello Greg John and Coy
just got out of the movie and I believe
is my favorite movie of the year and my
favorite combat movie ever oh also koi
fellow masshole here Franklin Mass
Franklin Mass okay here yeah uh I uh I I
think it might be one of the best combo
movies of all time I mean if this ends
up being what I my My Hope Is this
though is because it's one of those
things where beyond the spider verse God
forbid and the likelihood of this
happening very low
is that if Beyond this fighter verse
just happen to suck
it could actually affect the view the
way you reflect on uh across you know
when like a bad signal comes out and it
kind of affects your experience at the
prior installment that's the one part of
beyond the spider verse I'm concerned
about doing is affecting it a lot of
times it it a lot of times I can't that
might not be the effect but especially
when it is such a part two of a Trilogy
you know what I mean where it's like
obviously the story won't be complete
unless we get to part three it's not
just like I'm trying to think Infinity
War it's like Terminator 3 doesn't
affect Terminator two for me right right
you know because what if the game had
been bad how that would diminish
Infinity yeah yeah yeah
um so it did beyond the spider verse
does happen to have that potential of
doing that but yeah I think it's uh I
think it might be my favorite comic book
movie too which is just stack all the
time of all time I can't think of a
movie that I got such a this medium is
the only way to tell it this tells all
the things in the story the villains are
just as good as the heroes like this
might be my number one period wow
how do you think miles's relationship
with Peter thank you Carson letham miles
relationship with Peter B and Gwen are
going to be affected by the reactions in
this movie into the third movie I think
uh Peter B's kid is gonna die terribly
gonna have a tragic death it's going to
be the most violent first R-rated
Spider-Man movie we've ever gotten
um I thought Peter B part you know
what's funny I didn't miss Peter B
Parker at all and he showed up I was
like oh yeah yeah whereas I remember the
first time watching the spirals movie
had something to do with the marketing
and just being new with miles that I was
like waiting for him to show up sure but
this time around I didn't even have him
on my mind and then he then he shows up
it's incredible how the last five years
have made miles maybe the biggest Legacy
character of all time and I'm including
other Green Lanterns I'm including hell
even like Nightwing like they're Legacy
characters then there's Miles Morales
yeah he too so many people is Spider-Man
and I think that's so beautiful I think
they've really done something special
with the character I think he's a very
responsible dad though oh I was talking
about miles but yes no Peter B Parker is
uh I mean good luck yeah he literally
assures her he's not going to take the
baby yeah and he's like I'm just taking
this baby out yeah I hope the next movie
he's getting it I hope the three movies
he's having this like off-screen
relationship with Mary Jane he's not
with her he gets back with her as a kid
and the next trip he has a divorce for
being a terrible
dad's training order for both her and
the baby is she all doing the divorce
yeah but he was funny in this film again
Daredevil represents Mary Jane dude
spider Court Stacy's mom has gotta go
get it
over my Cannon going online you got it I
was just harmonizing with you you were
the lead you were the main part of the
melody G it's so good
[Music]
240 seconds Stacy's mom can an event
rules shouldn't apply to Miles when he's
an anomaly plus was never meant to be
Spider-Man loophole makes miles even
more unique than he oh really is
that's very true unfortunately we have
covered this topic quite a lot
um but yeah that I agree with you
that's what I got and you have a great
name
well and I think that also works too
because even if yeah even if the Canada
events shouldn't apply to him he still
is like this anomaly with great
potential to disturb the balance I think
they should make Donald Glover Prowler
in the MCU I'd love that Spider-Man four
needs a street level villain I think
having someone with like that power set
would work and they say there's in
storage to go back to their home
universes so we did cover this on your
stream Lab whale watchers media do you
guys think that inheritors will get used
we did talk about it quite extensively I
hate being one of those kind of
streamers but we did we're like but we
did talk about it in depth and of course
we got it and we talked about it to you
yeah that's true so we didn't
technically answer your question
stop yelling at us in the comments
appreciate the redundancy you might have
already left and been like they took too
long to get to my question hopefully
come back to the stream later and see
when they answered that's that happens a
lot crooked thank you crooked re-watch
first movie and it still hits a little
harder for me than this one did maybe I
gotta see it again didn't know spot and
your favorite villain well you know like
the first movie one of the best parts of
that film that core Dynamic of Peter B
Parker and miles is obviously a missing
element in this film but this is such a
different movie but there is such a
unique like charm and such a surprise to
seeing
this version of Peter Parker you know
yeah it's such a specific Peter Parker
and it was so you don't you and there's
also the wow surprise factor of doing
such a thing that is of course missing
um but you can't repeat that you can't
so they did something else different and
I I like what they did that was
different you know yeah
and uh Malik Curry it's pronounced Malik
I think I got it pretty close so stop
yelling at me thank you forget now and
oh yeah oh and uh didn't know spot new
favorite villain I'm gonna call my
favorite yet but you know we'll see how
he progresses terrific though yeah
love you Malik thank you and busy Brown
back at it to yell at everyone including
me yeah my very first Super Chat Rejoice
Rejects
multiple sounds
Connor Burroughs
if you three had a spider team like Gwen
who would be in it oh my God uh Tyrone
Magnus
Geeks and Gamers and uh
Andrew Tate yes perfect uh I'll take the
quartering
yeah who else is yelling out there I
mean I'll take Alex Jones on my team oh
my God Alex Jones yeah definitely gotta
get Alex Jones or some Joe Rogan on
there yeah The Joe Rogan perfect
sprinklers from Joe Rogan's house what
about you uh you know I'm gonna go uh
Bill Burr uh I'm making it fun a little
bit of a little better if we can bring
back anyone I got Heath Ledger on there
uh and then um
yeah then I can keep in Raleigh though
yeah I take him steal them all right
whatever he's my guy I'll hang out with
you because you got Ben running yeah my
muscles
we got to the last one right at the
three hour mark we did it here and
Craven the hunter is the next one to
continue Sony's great films and then
okay film Legacy yes hey man they had a
craven in the movie and uh for a second
I thought they were going to give us
Aaron Taylor oh my God we are not done
we got two more to do home stretch home
stretch we don't end the stream unless
we do it wrong
he's saying hey real rejects my phone my
foot is a microphone now I really
appreciate all the fun content you all
put out love the hours of entertainment
you provide like grade A comedy like my
foot is my microphone Coy you've
mentioned smooth 299 is your favorite
Spiderman can you share some of your
favorite comic runs I want to clarify
he's not my favorite he is a favorite
Spiderman he's not my favorite my
favorites Ultimate Spider-Man I believe
I can't keep up with oh that's fair it's
a big bit uh but uh Spider-Man 299 go
back and read these uh the Rick Leonardi
run Rick Leonardi's the artist they
modeled the Spider-Man after in this
movie as well uh yep he's uh the fifth
Turtle uh Rick Leonardi he's Leonardo's
cousin uh but Rick Leonardi is the
artist that did the style they modeled
it after it starts in 1992. it's
actually the first of the 20.99 imprint
you can get a collection of them you can
read the whole first Arc at once and
they're very very fun but very very 90s
so be prepared for that I think they
improved on him in the movie
Hells yeah Maybe
well done that's that's that's my that's
my pleasure you got it there it is
there's also a great crossover of
Spider-Man from the comics in 2099 and
uh like a time travel thing against
vulture 29.9 you might dig because it's
very multiversal oh Pinoy Pride bye
six a.m get some sleep
do you for a shirt They Come to Me Like
Jesus Jaden stevens or like God going to
Mary saying have Jesus hey guys it's my
first time donating hey
blocking you here
John John how do I get rid of this k
I'm not sure
I saved
all right please
hey guys my first time donating
hold on
[Music]
I just want to thank you all for what
you guys too it's a spider was my
favorite
fun rewatch
these these streams always go off the
race
they always start off with what happened
in this movie I gotta remember and I
want to be sharp I want to get good
videos
I don't know man miles did some and
it was good a fun rewatch I think he was
trying to warm miles and keep him away
from spider HQ before they got there
curious on your thoughts yeah he made it
really clear when he was like tearing
down the things that not only is that a
visual metaphor for tearing down the
establishment but he also said a really
clear line to that point being that make
sure you know who you're fighting with
before you enlist make sure you know the
war before you leave exactly so I think
that line was a pretty indicative of
what was going on and then I loved that
at the end he knew that spider-gwen
would eventually be the ones who help
him out so I I love that spider punk
though an anarchist was a good judge of
character and they made him a more
nuanced character by having me more than
just an anarchist he was an anarchist
with heart well and then because he's
Spider-Man and those Anarchist
Tendencies help at a crucial point when
a real Injustice seems to be being
rendered yeah aren't we the good guys
yeah and I and I liked yeah you have the
like little moment of Jessica Drew being
like Oh okay that's kind of getting to
me but you got spider Punk who's like
already on that wave exactly yeah and
and hey shouts out and love for Jessica
Drew we haven't mentioned her at all but
uh I like these are racist well no one's
really talking about her I noticed uh I
feel like she'll be more of a talking
point in the next movie yeah especially
when we see whoever her dad is and then
the man takes over I think and What's
the sex of the baby
gotta know
yeah uh we haven't um yeah no one's
really talked about uh Jessica Drew dude
start start chat wait she's also going
to be in um and uh there's a live action
Jessica Drew I believe in Madame whip
yeah yeah and I think that's gonna be
relevant and one of my favorite comic
cards is a mother Jessica Drew like as a
single mom uh you actually don't meet
the dad and uh porcupine Who does cameo
in this movie is the guy that Spider-Man
jumps off the train to just kick into
the uh Into The Ether he reforms and
becomes a good guy and he's actually the
babysitter for Jessica Drew's baby so I
thought that was a fun little Cameo for
Comic fans well guys um I thought this
was a great stream I feel like Coy
really did a great job today John I
thought you were even better than koi a
thousand points to you Whose Line Is It
Anyway read off the credits John
absolutely you're a football player uh
trying not to get arrested for sexual
harassment
X Phantom that's just my Phantom limb
touching your thigh there ooh olenti
don't let me make you feel uncomfortable
by getting awfully close to you here in
the chat Dariel Antonio oh no oh I am
not trying to grab that just just
reaching for some uh peanuts by the way
guys we're ending the stream right now I
hope you guys realize that's what's
happening
uh because of my horrific actions here
in the chat today ZB uh I'm not gonna go
with the joke I had lined up for that uh
juanpa PV uh you're gonna get HPV from
me when I uh touch yeah this is going
real great all right all right okay well
thank you thank you guys so much for
being here um this was another fun uh
stream spider stream we'll call it I
should have put that spider stream live
spider stream we got you just better
stream live spider stream uh all this
time didn't think about that but yeah
thank you guys so much for being here
this was a blast to do and uh koi thank
you for bringing your knowledge really
helps on these and your enthusiasm yeah
yeah it comes in handy an enthusiasm and
John um you are just the whole package
oh uh and more importantly thank you to
everyone who gave
all right
thank you spectacular yeah yeah thank
you
[Music]
perfect I didn't get to hear it at all
not once I heard it once through the
headphones quiet it's still the weirdest
thing to me because the the monitor was
working the monitor was working that's
how you heard it no it's done it's done
all right guys well thank you so much
and I'll talk with all of you relatively
soon all of you much love say hi to your
mother for me
peace out